chers collègues petite annonce avant de
démarrer sur notre audition du jour avec
notre collègue Thomas Cazenave et
plusieurs membres des trois groupes de
la majorité nous sommes rendus compte
que les dispositions que nous avons
votées dans la loi du 16 août 2022
portant en mesure d'urgence pour la
protection du pouvoir d'achat concernant
le plafonnement de l'indice des loyers
commerciaux pour les PME et de l'indice
de référence des loyers pour les ménages
arrive à expiration le 1er juillet donc
concrètement sans aucune intervention du
législateur les commerçants et les
locataires risquent de subir une hausse
brutale de leur loyer dans les
prochaines semaines c'est pourquoi une
proposition de loi visant à prolonger ce
plafonnement jusqu'au premier trimestre
2024 a donc été déposé hier avec
l'accord des secrétaires généraux de
tous les groupes politiques il a été
convenu de l'examiné en urgence il est
probable que cette proposition de loi
maintenant provisoirement un dispositif
de plafonnement de revalorisation de
variations annuelles des indices
locatifs soit inscrite à l'ordre du jour
de la séance du mercredi 31 mai où je
dis 1er juin c'est à dire la semaine
prochaine on a encore en attente de
l'information elle serait alors soumise
à notre commission le mardi 30 mai après
les QG je vous remercie de bien vouloir
déjà noter ces dates là 30 mai et
ensuite
le 31 ou le premier en hémicycle et
merci de votre flexibilité sur ce sujet
important sur lequel nous devons agir
sinon nous allons mettre un grand nombre
d'acteurs et personnes en difficulté sur
ce sujet je vous propose de désigner
Thomas Cazenave comme rapporteur
personne n'y voit d'inconvénient
très bien bah écoutez nous avançons avec
rapidité sur le sujet nous en arrivons
donc à notre audition du jour bonjour à
toutes et à tous la commission des
affaires économiques renoue ce matin
avec une pratique régulière sous la
précédente législature à savoir
l'organisation d'une table ronde
rassemblant les principaux opérateurs
des télécoms Orange SFR Bouygues Free et
la Fédération Française des Télécoms
mais les temps changent les réunions des
années passées portaient principalement
sur l'atteinte des objectifs du lieu
deal mobile un ensemble d'engagements
pris par les opérateurs en janvier 2018
pour accélérer la couverture mobile des
territoires la tenue de la présente
table ronde est plutôt justifiée par des
préoccupations tenant d'une part à la
fin annoncée du réseau cuivre et d'autre
part aux problèmes constatés dans le
déploiement de la fibre les services qui
utilisent le réseau cuivre en clair les
téléphones fixes et les abonnements
Internet ADSL cesseront de fonctionner
fin 2030 c'est Orange en tant que
propriétaire du réseau cuivre qui décide
et pilotes sa fermeture en fonction de
la progression du développement du
réseau de fibres optique alors sur le
papier cette transition technologique
est très rationnelle sur le terrain ce
beau dispositif semble connaître
quelques ratés et je pense que plusieurs
collègues en feront part ce matin
d'abord il est reproché à Orange un
certain manque de diligences dans
l'entretien du réseau cuivre ce qui peut
conduire les abonnés à être privé de
service durant plusieurs semaines voire
durant des mois la presse a aussi
mentionné récemment quelques
récriminations des autres opérateurs sur
le projet de libéralisation du prix
d'accès au réseau ADSL concernant le
déploiement de la fibre l'usage massif
de la sous-traitance a pu conduire à des
installations quelque peu baroques quand
elles ne dégrade pas les immeubles ou ne
provoquent pas des débranchements
d'autres abonnés en outre au constat un
ralentissement problématique des
déploiements de la fibre en zone d'appel
à manifestation d'intention
d'investissement et en zone très dense
ces diverses difficultés ont
particulièrement été relayées par notre
collègue Luc Lamirault avec lequel j'ai
que signé début février un courrier
adressé à Madame Christelle Hedman
directrice générale d'orange et
l'opérateur a jugé préférable de venir
s'expliquer directement devant la
représentation national c'est pourquoi
nous organisons cette table ronde je
précise qu'elle sera suivie la semaine
prochaine d'une autre table ronde
réunissant les opérateurs
d'infrastructures et nous aurons aussi
certainement l'occasion d'entendre la
recette le régulateur du secteur très
bien tôt
madame messieurs vous avez à présent la
parole pour votre propos introductif je
crois que Orange souhaité éventuellement
commencer c'est ce que on me disait ou
c'était la Fédération française très
bien Madame c'est à vous je vous laisse
se présenter chacun
5 minutes c'est ça ou une présentation
globale qu'il faudrait qu'on ait en 20
25 minutes 30 minutes grand maximum pour
qu'ensuite on puisse vous interroger
merci allez-y
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés nous sommes très
heureux de pouvoir échanger avec vous au
sujet donc de notre contribution à
l'aménagement numérique du territoire
qui nous tient beaucoup à coeur puisque
comme nous comme vous nous sommes les
promoteurs de l'investissement et de des
entreprises pour qu'elles viennent
s'installer dans les territoires nous
investissons 14,9 milliards d'euros en
2021 l'équivalent de 900 collèges nous
sommes des leviers en termes de
croissance puisque un euro investi par
les opérateurs télécoms c'est 6 euros de
croissance et un emploi dans les
télécoms génèrent 2,5 emplois dans le
secteur marchand 90% des Français sont
internautes donc nous sommes conscients
nos responsabilités à cet égard nous
sommes fiers des réalisations qui ont
été faites grâce aussi à toutes les
équipes des opérateurs mais nous sommes
aussi conscients du chemin qui reste
parfois
parcourir et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous répondons présents
aujourd'hui et nous sommes prêts
évidemment à répondre à toutes vos
interrogations sur le New Deal mobile je
comprends du président qui a insatisfait
site général qui rejoint celui de la
Cour des comptes qui nous a été délivré
en septembre 2021 même si nous ne sommes
pas au bout du processus
99,8% de la population et aujourd'hui
couverte par au moins trois opérateurs
en 4G nous avons livré
2467 sites du dispositif de couverture
ciblée dans les zones les plus rurales
il reste encore 1200 sites à identifier
nous en avons bien conscience le
dispositif s'étale jusqu'au 31 décembre
2027 et nous sommes à l'heure des
échéances qui ont déjà été passés nous
avons aussi 99% des sites des 102632
sites sur les territoires national qui
fonctionne aujourd'hui en 4G nous avons
une densité de sites mobiles qui a un
niveau extrêmement retrouver en Europe
nous avons 6% de plus de sites par
habitant qu'en Allemagne 10% de plus
qu'en Italie 27% de plus qu'au
Royaume-Uni alors même que nous avons
une topographie qui n'est pas
particulièrement facile et favorable et
un nombre important de zones qui
méritent d'une protection spéciale j'y
reviendrai en conclusion au niveau du
fixe nous avons aussi le record d'Europe
en termes de nombre de lignes nous avons
trois 34,4 millions de locaux
raccordables dans les réseaux
d'initiatives publiques ça a été décuplé
en 50
nous comprenons aussi qu'il reste malgré
tout des impatiences et des
insatisfactions l'ARCEP a mesuré
notamment la qualité des infrastructures
et à donner des premiers chiffres qui
seront complétés à d'ici cet été la
présidente de l'ARCEP a indiqué que il y
avait un taux de 1% du parc dans lequel
le service et les interventions pour
améliorer la qualité du rapport de mon
dépassé 1,2% donc dans ces zones nous
avons concentré nos efforts nous avons
construit un plan pour améliorer la
qualité des raccordements pour reprendre
les infrastructures qui étaient parfois
atypiques sur lequel je pense nous
aurons l'occasion de revenir
et si nous avons des propositions pour
améliorer encore la qualité de service
et pour renforcer
et l'accélération des déploiements c'est
au niveau de la fibre plutôt par la
vigilance du régulateur et par la
facilitation des déploiements que la loi
doit intervenir
nous devons mieux anticiper notamment
les contraintes environnementales et
débloquer 1700 sites qui potentiellement
en zone littoral pourraient connaître
des difficultés il y a une proposition
loi notamment de Xavier battue qui a été
déposé sur ce sujet et nous avons aussi
beaucoup de questions à traiter au
niveau des raccordements électriques
tous ne nécessite pas l'intervention de
la loi il y a d'abord le lancement des
études dès la signature des baux qui
permettrait d'accéder d'accélérer
considérablement donc l'instruction des
autorisations d'urbanisme par rapport à
des piloniodiles mais aussi à des
pylônes qui sont nécessaires pour
renforcer la qualité de service et tout
simplement soutenir la croissance des
usages il y a aussi des incertitudes qui
méritent des traités par la loi
notamment sur la prise en charge des
raccordements donc nous proposons de
fixer dans la loi une règle selon
laquelle les opérateurs télécoms
prennent en charge les raccordements de
plus de 100 mètres parce qu'aujourd'hui
il y a une incertitude qui crée des
délais
inutiles dans les déploiements et il y
avait aussi des dispositions excellentes
dans la loi Elan qui était simplement
expérimentale qui sont venus à échéance
au 31 décembre 2022 donc là aussi il y
aurait sans doute un intérêt à proroger
cette expérimentation en faire un
dispositif pérenne puisque il a produit
des résultats très positifs je vous
remercie merci beaucoup qui souhaitent
continuer monsieur Guérin
ce qui est en général d'Orange allez-y
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
d'avoir je vous remercie de cette
invitation qui nous permet effectivement
d'échanger sur des sujets qui nous
tiennent à coeur côté orange et je sais
qu'il vous tiennent à cœur également
aussi je voudrais partager avec vous
trois messages très rapidement mais
d'abord vous vous dire que sur la
question de la qualité du client en fait
aujourd'hui on a des débats assez
importants avec l'ARCEP sur
effectivement comment faire en sorte que
cette qualité soit gérée dans le cadre
de l'extinction du du réseau cuivre on a
aussi malheureusement quelques
contentieux avec certains de nos
camarades ici présents opérateurs sur
cette qualité on a aussi une question de
modèle économique dans l'avenir pour
financer la qualité du cuivre donc je
répondrai à toutes vos questions mais
sur la qualité de cuivre il y a un
certain nombre de questions auxquelles
je ne pourrais pas répondre du fait de
cette situation du je viens de de
décrire donc je voulais vous le dire en
toute transparence d'emblée voilà donc
ce qu'on vous propose c'est si c'est
d'organiser peut-être une autre réunion
si ça vous va pour que on vous dise tout
droit dans les yeux encore une fois
l'idée n'est pas de de cacher ou
d'éviter les réponses mais de pouvoir le
faire
le contexte que j'ai expliqué
précédemment les trois messages que je
voulais vous adresser le premier
effectivement celui que Lisa a déjà
adressé qui est que sans nier
effectivement les difficultés qu'on peut
rencontrer sur la fibre il faut se
satisfaire de la situation dans laquelle
on est certes 0 1% de ligne un problème
correspondent à des dizaines de milliers
de foyers qui sont mécontents mais
globalement regarder les chiffres aussi
de ce qui a été fait et vous verrez que
on reste nous opérateur très très
mobilisés sur ces réalisations Rennes
chez Orange c'est 34000 34000 salariés
qui travaillent sur sur le sur la fibre
aujourd'hui c'est 50 millions de
raccordement THD qui ont été fait à
travers le monde par Orange afin 21 on
porte l'essentiel de ces investissements
9 milliards d'euros sur la fibre optique
en France 60% des 35 millions de locaux
éligible au FTTH sont raccordable grâce
aux investissements au primo
investissement d'orange donc on a passé
les différents jalons on est en train de
passer les différents jalons sur les
différentes zones qui nous étaient
demandées donc on est vraiment
effectivement au rendez-vous de ce
déploiement de ce déploiement et le plan
les entreprises qui annoncé cristallet
de Man qui est lisent le futur
s'appuient et renforce encore cette
volonté d'orange d'être au rendez-vous
en 2025 des déploiements pour que
effectivement tous nos concitoyens
puissent accéder à une fibre de qualité
en attendant la suppression du cuivre
d'ici 2030 ça c'était mon premier
message mon deuxième message était de
vous confirmer l'implication quotidienne
de nos équipes sur la question de la QS
de la fibre il y a des ya aucun doute on
prend ce sujet très très au sérieux pour
améliorer le service qu'on offre à nos
clients alors derrière cette question de
CSI bon mais énormément de sujets
différents il y a pour moi des sujets
qui le relèvent des zoïdes des sujets
qui relèvent des opérateurs commerciaux
des sujets qui relèvent de la
sous-traitance donc sur les eux il y en
a deux il y a tout ce qui est
effectivement ces réseaux anciens ou
qu'il faut remettre en conformité il y a
des plans qui ont été proposés par les
opérateurs concernés rangent des temps
pas concernés ces plans sont suivis par
la recette ils se déroulent il faut leur
laisser le temps je crois de d'avancer
mais ces prix au sérieux il y a ensuite
côté aussi aussi une autre côté oui
aussi une autre question qui est tout ce
que vous connaissez bien c'est plats de
nouilles c'est boîtier dans les rues qui
sont ouverts qui ne sont pas sécurisés
donc sachez que l'opérateur
d'infrastructure qui est orange
prendrait sur au service de cette
situation on a repris 2000 de ses points
sensibles l'année dernière on a prévu
d'en reprendre 5000 cette année et on va
continuer donc à supprimer ces
planouilles à re sécuriser nos boîtiers
nos points de mutilation des conscients
que ce n'est pas qu'un problème pour les
yeux c'est aussi un problème
d'exploitation donc en tant que nous
sommes attentifs ces deux sujets là en
tant qu'opérateur commercial vous avez
un plan qui a été défini par la FFT mis
en oeuvre qui traite en quatre points
que Lisa évoqué tout à l'heure qui se
déploie aussi qui est la certification
des des sous-traitants que vous
connaissez tous ces sujets là ça
simplement ça commence à effectivement
donner des premières résultats si tu es
une bonne chose et puis le dernier sujet
qui reste c'est effectivement la
sous-traitance qu'on n'oublie pas non
plus puisque effectivement pour avoir
des travaux de qualité il faut une
sous-traitance de qualité donc on le
traite par la certification qui est un
des quatre points mais on le traite
aussi par des augmentations de
rémunération puisqu'on a augmenté
pendant la période covid on avait
augmenté très considérablement les
rémunérations des sous-traitants on a
continué à le faire l'année dernière
avec des augmentations de 3,5 % là je
parle d'orange et on vient d'augmenter
encore les tarifs cette semaine de 4 %
pour effectivement permettre à nos
sous-traitants d'absorber on a aussi
simplifier énormément les relations
contractuelles qu'on avait avec eux pour
supprimer tout ce qui est surcharge coût
inefficace procédure
inefficace on est parfois des
entreprises de ta différentes donc on a
simplifié c'était vraiment le deuxième
message que je voulais vous adresser qui
est que la QS five est vraiment pris
très au sérieux par les opérateurs et
ces quatre points ces trois ou quatre
points que je viens de d'évoquer son
traité et donne déjà des résultats le
dernier point que je voulais
à évoquer avec vous bah c'est vous
rassurer sur le fait alors je sais que
vous aimez l'épreuve et pas simplement
les déclarations mais vous rassurer sur
le fait que nous serons au rendez-vous
de du généralisation de la fibre optique
en 2025 donc nous n'avons pas arrêté de
déployer contrairement ce que je dis de
six dollars nous avons continué à le
faire nous continuerons à le faire il
reste à un certain nombre de prises à
faire nous les ferons d'ici 2025 je le
dis devant vous il y a un certain nombre
de sujets qui doivent être réglés pour
nous aider à les faire je pense
particulièrement raccordement complexe
au raccordement sur les propriétés
privées sur lequel on n'a pas encore de
solution
définitive et efficace en tout cas
industrielle on a proposé un guichet de
cohésion numérique
unique qui permettrait de gérer ces
sujets il faut maintenant avancer donc
vous avez d'une part le déploiement de
la fille qui va se poursuivre et d'autre
part la fermeture du cuivre qui qui se
déroule des expérimentations se
déroulent les unes après les autres on
en est à la deuxième on est là sur des
expérimentations avec plusieurs
centaines de milliers de foyers
concernés tout se passe bien c'est le
fameux lot 2 on va bientôt publier des
résultats précis il faut encore qu'on
améliore le dispositif notamment dans la
relation qu'on a avec les collectivités
locales mais tout ça est en cours pour
que effectivement d'ici 2030 au plus
tard on puisse éteindre ce cuivre et
permettre à nos concitoyens de basculer
sur la fibre et puis quand entre 26 et
30 il n'auront pas encore la fibre leur
permettent aussi d'avoir des
technologies plus efficaces le satellite
on a des nouvelles générations de
satellites qu'on commercialise et puis
la 4G Fiat la sainte gifix qui sont
aussi des solutions de qualité pour
augmenter les débits la qualité de
service voilà j'étais trop long pardon
mais c'est un petit peu les trois
messages qu'on voulait vous passer en
attendant les questions qui je suppose
seront nombreuses merci beaucoup
Monsieur le Secrétaire général je vous
propose donc de passer monsieur aligny
ce cataire général du groupe Altice SFR
merci d'être là c'est à vous
je vous laisse appuyer sur le bouton
voilà c'est parfait on est bon merci
Monsieur président mesdames messieurs
députés avant tout merci merci de nous
recevoir et nous donner l'opportunité de
nous exprimer à cette à cette table
ronde je pense que Lisa et Nicolas ont
déjà bien évoqué les sujets du secteur
donc je me permettrai de me concentrer
un peu plus sur sur le groupe Altis SFR
et sur
les engagements que nous avons pris ces
engagements réels qui ont qui
[Musique]
se matérialisent maintenant depuis
plusieurs années ça ils sont du plan
très haut débit d'une part en matière
d'investissement le groupe Altis
investissent cinq années près de 3
milliards d'euros dans les
infrastructures Telecom d'autre part
nous réalisons un déploiement massif
d'infrastructures Télécom et ça ça vaut
également pour mes camarades autour de
cette table ronde
on déploie à mars forcée sur le
territoire et ça c'est sans égal à
l'échelle à l'échelle européenne
pour vous donner un petit peu d'éléments
chiffrés côté mobile aujourd'hui SFR
c'est une couverture 4G de 99,8%
une couverture dans le cadre d'une odeal
une couverture de 63% en 5G avec plus de
7300 communes ouvertes
ces déploiements n'ont pas été épargnés
par les difficultés
par la crise du par la crise du covid
par des moratoire par des contraintes
sanitaires ainsi que des contraintes de
déploiement liées à des dispositifs
légaux comme la loi Littoral que vous
connaissez aujourd'hui c'est ce qui nous
freine un petit peu dans le déploiement
même si nous déploignons de manière
intensive et accéléré
côté fibre et FX et c'est faire
aujourd'hui c'est 32 millions de prises
HD commercialisables
avec
à ce stade via notre filiale XP fibre
plus de 6 millions de prises déployées
en zone moyennement dense
grâce
à la mobilisation des pouvoirs publics
des collectivités et des de l'ensemble
des acteurs de la filière je pense qu'on
peut dire aujourd'hui et on peut tous
s'en féliciter que le plan France 3D
débit est un succès comme le lui dit
nous avons réussi en moins de 10 ans à
apporter la fibre aux Français là où la
construction d'un réseau de transport
d'électricité a pris près de 50 ans faut
pas l'oublier
la grande majorité des déploiements
s'agissant de la fibre sont aujourd'hui
derrière nous mais il faut aller au bout
il y a encore un certain nombre de
déploiements à réaliser parler Nicolas
parler des déploiements complexes
on a bien conscience que aujourd'hui
tous nos concitoyens qui ne sont pas
encore fibrés cette attente est
insupportable on y travaille
collectivement pour répondre à leurs
attentes et déployer au plus vite
par ailleurs comme ça déjà été évoqué il
y a certaines zones qui sont
particulièrement accidentogènes vous
avez certaines zones en Île-de-France ou
le taux d'échec au raccordement le taux
SAV est plus et plus important que la
normale ça concerne certains réseaux
spécifiques certains réseaux qu'on
qualifie d'atypiques on en a
parfaitement confiance mais
il n'en demeure pas moins que ça cela
concerne un nombre mineur de
dysfonctionnement et d'incident alors il
ne s'agit pas là de minimiser ses
incidents mais plutôt de les remettre en
perspective avec le déploiement de 80%
du territoire aujourd'hui
qui s'est fait à marche forcée en moins
de 10 ans déployer la fibre aussi vite
ça ne se fait pas sans difficulté mais
il ne faut pas minimiser ces difficultés
comme je l'indique et nous opérateurs
autour de sa table on est là justement
pour
réparer tous ces toutes ces malfaçons
tous ces dysfonctionnements comme
comment est-ce qu'on fait ça comment
est-ce qu'on fait ça il y a des mesures
qui ont été prises en place qui ont été
mises en place par la filière les contre
d'intervention les certifications les
habitations le partage des plannings
avec pour conséquence que on voit
aujourd'hui même si il faudra faire un
état d'élus à la fin de l'année c'est ce
qui est prévu on voit une nette
amélioration
en termes d'incident et d'accidentologie
couplé à cela vous avez comme le disait
Nicolas la reprise de certains réseaux
il y a certains opérateurs sous les jets
de la recette qui ont décidé de lancer
des plans de reprise en l'occurrence
nous via une filiale expéfibre nous
avons lancé un plan de reprise de réseau
atypique essentiellement réseau en
Île-de-France ou nous reprenons 900 PM
900 points de mutualisation ce sont les
armoires de rue que vous connaissez qui
représente l'équivalent de 400 000
prises
ce plan a démarré fin 2022 les premiers
résultats de l'arsèques puisque l'ARCEP
contrôle ce plan de manière quotidienne
hebdomadaire mensuelle son programme
nous avons reçu un premier satisfait de
la recette et c'est un plan qui va
s'étaler jusqu'en jusqu'en 2024 avec
pour principal objectif
diminuer l'accidentologie de ces réseaux
croyez donc que notre objectif ce n'est
pas de minimiser les problèmes mais
c'est surtout de la résoudre
ce plan de déploiement de la fibre
à ça vient s'adosser un grand projet qui
est le la fermeture du cuivre
on ne pourrait pas on ne pourra pas
réaliser avec succès la fermeture du
cuir
être
sans avoir réussi se déploiement de la
fibre
s'agissant du déploiement du cuivre il y
a un point qu'on aimerait apporter à
votre attention c'est que nous aurons
besoin de tous les acteurs de la filière
nous aurons besoin des pouvoirs des
collectivités pour une chose bien
précise
adopter une communication neutre et
pédagogique pour pour permettre à tous
nos concitoyens de bien prendre
conscience de la fermeture du cuir et
leur expliquer tout simplement comment
passer à la fibre nous aurons besoin de
vous
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur Kater
général je vous propose de passer à
Monsieur Lombardini président du conseil
d'administration d'Iliade bienvenue et
merci d'être avec nous merci monsieur le
Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés merci
de nous entendre aujourd'hui je vais pas
par raser mais mes camarades juste
quelques quelques points le premier
c'est ce je pense qu'on peut avant de
porter le regard sur les choses qui ne
fonctionnent pas
se réjouir du succès du plan très haut
débit qui est un sujet je pense assez
largement transpartisan qui est un sujet
très français dans la mesure où on est
bon dans les infrastructures et on a
collectivement construit de façon très
efficace c'est-à-dire que on a un seul
réseau dans la plupart des territoires
nous on a l'expérience également de la
Pologne de l'Italie de l'Irlande où on
voit souvent des réseaux concurrents
donc quelque chose de compliqué pour à
la fois l'investissement et les
utilisateurs en France on a vraiment
construit un réseau je pense très
proprement même si je ne néglige pas les
petits problèmes qui demeurent et on a
réussi à faire travailler ensemble la
puissance publique à la fois l'état
central les collectivités locales les
opérateurs alternatifs l'opérateur
historique avec l'aide du régulateur et
des gouvernements successifs pour faire
un projet qui nous met à la première
place en Europe en nombre de foyers
effectivement raccordés au très haut
débit
il y a cinq ou sept ans on était très
loin dans les classements donc
commençons par nous réjouir de cela le
deuxième point sur lequel je voudrais
porter l'attention c'est que les
opérateurs alternatifs les trois qui
sont à cette table ont pris plus de la
moitié de l'investissement privé en
charge il faut rendre hommage au travail
je dirais d'exécution de construction
des réseaux qui a été fait par par
Orange mais au travers du co-financement
on est dans un modèle vertueux où les
opérateurs alternatifs portent une très
large part des investissements
deuxième point pour parler de nous un
petit instant on est le premier
opérateur alternatif en France donc le
premier opérateur derrière l'opérateur
historique avec un peu plus de 7
millions de foyers abonnés à l'Internet
fixe au travers de nos offres et on a
dansait déjà migré deux tiers de ces 7
millions d'abonnés à la fibre depuis
2018 on ne propose que la fibre dès lors
qu'on est sur une zone qu'on a
effectivement fibrée on ne vend plus
d'un DSL sur les zones où la fibre est
disponible néanmoins on constate que sur
des réseaux qui sont ouverts depuis plus
de 5 ans il reste environ 10% d'abonnés
cuivre qui sont réticents à migrer à la
fibre même quand c'est au même prix même
quand c'est dans le même contrat même
quand on prend en charge la totalité des
travaux de raccordement
et ça ça mène au point suivant qui est
la fermeture technique du cuivre ça nous
paraît un sujet essentiel pour trois
raisons la première c'est que on peut
pas s'offrir collectivement de réseau
nationaux avec un nombre d'abonnés qui
ne change pas le coût devient démesuré
le deuxième aspect il est
environnemental le réseau cuivre coûte
très cher en énergie et encore plus ces
derniers temps et le troisième c'est ces
fameux 10% d'abonnés qui je pense chez
tous les opérateurs demeure sur le
cuivre quoi qu'il arrive tant qu'il
existe
c'est important d'utiliser la fermeture
technique pour arriver à les faire
migrer
donc en résumé on pense que la
régulation donc les travaux de la
recette menaient en ce moment devrait
mener à une organisation qui favorise
cette fermeture technique et de la faire
le plus rapidement possible alors je
sais que vous êtes des élus proches des
territoires il s'agit pas de créer la
panique mais bien de faire une fermeture
qui soit propre et organisée donc on a
vraiment besoin de travailler ensemble
c'est pas juste le sujet d'orange ou
juste le sujet des opérateurs c'est un
sujet collectif de même qu'à une époque
il a fallu arrêter la télévision
analogique et les expérimentations nous
laissent assez optimistes sur le fait
que tout ceci est assez gérable dernier
point sur la fibre
là c'est vraiment un point très
important alors il est
conjoncturellement
sur le devant de la scène à l'occasion
d'une PPL nous on pense de façon très
claire qu'il faut pas changer
l'organisation industrielle on ne nie
pas le fait qu'il y a quelques pourcents
de lignes sur lesquelles il peut y avoir
des problèmes et on les traite de façon
très organisée avec l'ARCEP
anthropopopérateurs entre autres et OC
avec le regard vigilant du gouvernement
des pouvoirs publics et le vôtre mais
remettre en cause le modèle qui
aujourd'hui est organisé si je le
schématisais il y a 32 millions
d'abonnés fixes qui dialogue avec les
quatre opérateurs commerciaux que vous
avez face à vous qui eux-mêmes sont en
relation avec une centaine d'opérateurs
d'immeubles d'oïdes opérateurs de réseau
l'idée de remplacer ce schéma qui
fonctionne qui a été long à mettre en
place avec des systèmes d'information
des contrats des salariés des
sous-traitants dont le bouleverser au
milieu du gué pour dire finalement les
odeurs les opérateurs de réseau qui vont
être les interlocuteurs des abonnés et
les ossés les opérateurs commerciaux qui
vont parler à la centaine de oui c'est
la certitude qu'on arrête tout pendant
24 mois
alors vu de chez nous opérateur je vais
vous dire c'est pas forcément un drame
parce que on va arrêter les
investissements et l'activité fibre va
enfin générer du cash je dis ça de façon
un peu provocante je pense pas que ce
soit l'objectif que de se dire on arrête
le déploiement de la fibre alors que ça
fonctionne parce qu'il y a moins d'1 %
des lignes qui posent problème donc vous
l'avez compris on est très engagé je
pense tous les quatre autour de la table
sur le plan qualité
l'ARCEP nous suit de très près
le gouvernement également on prend des
engagements qui sont forts mais
laissez-nous le temps de délivrer la
promesse de qualité avant de changer le
modèle qui aura des effets
catastrophiques merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président je
vous propose de terminer ce tour de
table avec Monsieur de Tournade
directeur des affaires réglementaires de
Bouygues Telecom merci monsieur le
Président je m'inscris bien sûr dans les
propos qui viennent d'être tenus pour ma
part rappeler peut-être que vous le
Télécom n'est pas un opérateur
d'infrastructure mais un opérateur
commercial mais un opérateur commercial
qui coin investit dans les
infrastructures donc qui participent
pleinement à leur financement voilà moi
je centrerai mon propos sur la qualité
de la fibre qui est une des questions
posées à cette table ronde et je profite
de cette occasion pour vous assurer de
notre plein d'engagement dans le plan
qualité de la filière qui a été annoncé
ces derniers mois voilà nous croyons
vraiment que c'est l'amélioration des
processus industriels de raccordement le
renforcement de la formation des
intervenants et la reprise des réseaux
accidentogène qui résorbera dans le
futur rapidement les difficultés pour
notre part nous croyons beaucoup
l'amélioration des processus on fait
beaucoup de propositions sur le sujet
par le passé et encore maintenant voilà
transmettons bien sûr nos plaques
d'intervention Zoé qui nous le demandent
nous auditons nos sous-traitants
régulièrement nos intervenants sur le
terrain nous avons limité très tôt aussi
le rendre sous-traitance adorant ça
c'était important de le faire le
processus d'un d'autocertification de
l'intervenant les temps court chez nous
il est relativement bien avancé nous
avons également développé très tôt
l'outil et intervention on y reviendra
peut-être qui permet de détecter les
déconnexions des clients sur le terrain
voilà qui permet comme ça l'opérateur
commercial du client qui a été
déconnecté pour intervenir proactivement
sur le terrain pour lui rétablir sa
connexion et nous proposons même d'aller
un petit peu plus loin sur cet outil de
passer à une phase 2 qui permettra à
l'intervenance sur le terrain qui a
déconnecté malencontreusement le client
de pouvoir le rétablir sa connexion
directement quand il est encore sur le
terrain et ça permettra à tout le monde
de gagner beaucoup de temps voilà alors
vous le croirez ou pas mais c'est
pourtant exactement vérité nous sommes
vraiment en empathie avec tous nos
clients la raison notre raison d'être
c'est d'améliorer la vie numérique de
nos clients de répondre à leurs
problématique de résoudre leurs
problèmes voilà je citerai quelques
exemples par exemple très brièvement
voilà quand un client perd sa connexion
par exemple et ben nous lui mettons à
disposition un galet 4G qui permet de
pouvoir rétablir une connexion Internet
le temps de résoudre son problème on
fait également des remises sur facture
le plan d'interruption en cas de
malfaçon provoquer lors d'un encadrement
chez le client on a défini mis en place
un processus de traitement de ces
malfaçons donc on vient chez le client
régler remettre en état ce qui a été ce
qui a été mis en désordre voilà s'il y a
également besoin de travaux en domaine
privatif et ben on propose à nos clients
une liste de sous-traitants voilà qu'on
a un petit peu référencé qui permet aux
clients de pouvoir créer
mettre en conformité son installation
pour réaliser le raccordement voilà et
enfin je dirais voilà tout bad buzz sur
la fibre est très judiciable à notre
image et c'est vraiment pas notre
intérêt à nous faire perdurer les
difficultés et on met vraiment tout en
oeuvre avec la filière pour résoudre
tous ces difficultés
merci merci beaucoup merci pour ce
premier tour de table je vous propose
maintenant de passer aux orateurs de
groupe alors le principe je vous le
rappelle c'est 4 minutes par orateur de
groupe inclut votre réponse donc la
personne qui vous interroge j'ai la
possibilité de s'arrêter au bout de
quelques secondes et faire un jeu de
ping-pong avec vous ça peut être une
minute ça peut être deux minutes maximum
3 minutes histoire de vous laisser
toujours une minute de réponse le chrono
est juste derrière ici alors comme vous
êtes cinq aujourd'hui je vous propose si
c'est possible d'orienter votre question
vers un des interlocuteurs ou alors de
votre côté de choisir qui répond et
d'alterner vis-à-vis des 10 orateurs de
groupe une fois qu'on a précisé les
règles je vous propose de commencer avec
Monsieur Eric Bothorel du groupe
Renaissance
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
Messieurs chers collègues des politiques
ambitieuses dans le secteur des télécoms
ont été mises en oeuvre sous la
précédente mandature le plan France très
haut débit porté par notre majorité à
fixer l'objectif de la généralisation de
la fibre optique d'ici 2025 grâce à un
investissement sans précédentes publics
et privé l'objectif de 80 % de
couverture fin 2022 et quasiment atteint
avec un déploiement satisfaisant dans la
majorité des cas faisant aujourd'hui en
France le pays le plus avancé en Europe
en termes de déploiement de la fibre et
nous pouvons je crois nous en féliciter
en parallèle la généralisation du très
haut débit mobile a été rendue possible
par le New Deal mobile en Bretagne par
exemple
deux tiers des sites en couverture
ciblée était en service fin 2022
l'objectif est clair parvenir à une
complétude des réseaux fixes et mobiles
toutefois des disparités territoriales
subsistes en matière d'accès à la fibre
en plus d'insuffisance de qualité pour
certains raccordement et de difficultés
liées aux raccordement complexes le tout
dans un contexte de fermeture prochaine
du réseau cuivre alors quelle solution
une initiative législative a vu le jour
au Sénat l'été dernier avec l'objectif
d'ancrer dans la loi des modifications
structurelles du modèle utilisé jusqu'à
lors ainsi que des engagements pris par
la filière à la rentrée 2022 ces
engagements remettent les opérateurs
d'infrastructure au cœur des dispositifs
renforce le dialogue entre les parties
prenantes
sous l'égide des pouvoirs publics et de
la SEP actes un meilleur contrôle des
raccordements limite la sous-traitance
cela va me semble-t-il dans le bon sens
juste à lui en parallèle initiative du
ministre barreau de réunir les parties
prenantes afin de parvenir un accord
global pour parachever le déploiement de
la fibre en contrepartie de la forme de
défiscalité des télécoms l'ouverture
d'une réflexion autour de l'ifère ou du
fer cher me semble opportune à cet égard
aussi pouvez-vous nous dresser un
premier bilan des engagements pris en
septembre 2022 et nous exposer également
l'état des lieux en matière demplitude
des réseaux fixes et mobiles notamment
en zone littorale je serai par ailleurs
preneur de vos retours sur la façon dont
vous accueillez le très attendu filtre
anti-arnaque et la manière dont vous
êtes mis à contribution pour le faire
fonctionner dans le cadre du prochain
texte de loi à venir je vous remercie
merci beaucoup alors en deux minutes qui
souhaiterait répondre
allez-y
merci Monsieur monsieur botterel donc au
sujet tout d'abord de la complétude de
la mise en oeuvre du plan donc qui a été
arrêté en septembre 2022
donc nous avons tous limités les rangs
de sous-traitance à deux c'était un
point très important pour la qualité des
interventions et pour le pilotage des
interventions par les opérateurs
commerciaux nous avons tous aussi
commencer à mettre en oeuvre la
certification et les dispositifs de taux
certification des intervenants donc
l'objectif est ensuite
après après l'été à la fin de l'année
d'opérer un audit de ce dispositif pour
passer le cas échéant à une phase 2 nous
avons aussi tous mis en oeuvre y
intervention il intervention c'est un
dispositif très important puisqu'il
permet d'identifier celui qui est
intervenu sur le point de mutualisation
de transmettre immédiatement
l'information sur le respect des normes
à l'opérateur d'infrastructure à
l'opérateur commercial et ensuite pour
chacun d'intervenir sur le point de
mutualisation pour repérer les éventuels
déconnexions et les traiter le plus
rapidement possible nous avons des
objectifs de 75% de conformité des
séries photos
en juillet et puis on va passer à 95%
l'année prochaine
sur la reprise des infrastructures ça
c'est la qualité de l'art qui est
importante pour que toutes les prises
soient correctement reprises sur la
reprise des infrastructures il y a un
plan extrêmement ambitieux Orange vous a
déjà donné quelques chiffres pour ces
réseaux il y a des plans qui ont été
certifiés par la recette et qui sont mis
en oeuvre en associant les collectivités
territoriales dans les quelques réseaux
qui sont accidentogènes donc ce suivi il
effectué avec vigilance par l'ARCEP il a
réuni tous il y a quelques quelques
semaines et qui va publier des
indicateurs d'ici l'été et qui serviront
ensuite de référence pour regarder
l'amélioration sur les réseaux
effectivement il faudra plusieurs mois
encore pour arriver à le mettre en œuvre
complètement mais la trajectoire
merci beaucoup je vous propose de passer
à Monsieur Aurélien Lopez gle
merci monsieur le Président en septembre
dernier j'ai eu l'opportunité d'être
rapporteur sur le projet loi de finance
vous les Télécom et d'un rapport j'avais
eu l'occasion de vous auditionner je
suis allé malfaçon les retards de
déploiement ou encore sur les
raccordements des zones complexes
j'avais d'ailleurs proposé ici dans
cette commission un amendement pour
augmenter les fins loués aux zones
complexes qui avait été adoptées en
commission des Affaires d'économiques
mais qui avait été refusé par la
majorité en commission des finances
vu que je vous ai déjà auditionné sur
ces sujets lors des auditions je vais
vous entraîner sur un sujet un peu
annexe lors des auditions vous avez
clairement dénoncé une fiscalité
inadaptée voire discriminante à votre
rencontre je pense à lui faire et à la
Tosse alors même que vous êtes en
période d'investissement lourd dans nos
réseaux
en parallèle vous avez les gafames qui
s'accaparent toujours plus la bande
passante au total ce sont cinq
plateformes telles que Google Netflix ou
Amazon qui capte plus de la moitié du
trafic donc le résultat c'est que vous
vous retrouvez dans une situation où
vous devez investir toujours plus pour
supporter un trafic qui ne cesse de
s'alourdir
et pendant que des grandes sociétés
américaines qui en plus ne presque ne
paye presque pas d'un point en France
ce gavent sur vos investissements et
donc nos investissements
d'où une proposition judicieuse que KFC
la Fédération des fédérations Télécom et
vous-même c'est d'établir une taxe sur
la bande passante pour faire payer au
gafam une taxe proportionnelle à la
place qu'ils occupent sur le réseau on
me quand j'en avais discuté un peu avec
vous et puis on m'avait répondu que
c'était un sujet européen qui devait
être traité au niveau européen et que
d'ailleurs donc il y a une consultation
européenne qui a commencé en début de
l'année mais je me posais la question
est-ce qu'on devrait se limiter
est-ce qu'on devrait pas prendre les
devants et nous-mêmes aller en avant
Bruno Le Maire n'a pas attendu
l'Union européenne pour faire une tasse
Gafa
et aujourd'hui aujourd'hui donc nous ne
sommes pas obligés d'atteindre l'Union
européenne et peut-être il serait
intéressant de
prendre notre sillage l'Union européenne
commencer à éditer une norme et donc la
question que je voulais vous poser c'est
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
possible donc d'entraîner lieu dans
notre science et est-ce que vous avez
une idée des raisons de cette lenteur de
l'Union européenne sur ce sujet ça fait
quand même plusieurs années qu'on en
parle merci merci beaucoup alors en une
minute trente qui souhaitent répondre
donc au départ c'était une taxe qui
était accessoire à la CVAE qui va être
supprimé d'ici la fin de l'année cette
taxe va subsister la CVAE elle était
destinée à corriger un effet de Ben de
125 millions d'euros elle attend
aujourd'hui 270 millions d'euros nous
proposons une stabilisation
intertemporelle de cette impôt puisqu'il
va diminuer mécaniquement avec le
décommunitionnement de la 2G et de la 3G
sur le TT faire cher alors c'est pas
vraiment une taxe c'est plutôt une
contribution au financement du réseau
puisqu'il y a un
déficit d'investissement à l'horizon
2030 de 174 milliards d'euros qui a
exposé la Commission européenne donc
nous venons la Fédération Française de
télécom de répondre à la consultation
publique annoncé par Thierry Breton qui
vient de s'achever le 19 mai et en
septembre il y aura une annonce de la
Commission européenne et du commissaire
breton sur ce qu'il fera de cet
instrument c'est important d'agir à
l'échelle européenne parce que sinon il
risque d’ailleurs des mécanismes de
contournement donc on sera plus fort à
l'échelle européenne et ce sera
pertinent aussi au regard de l'échelle
des investissements des réseaux d'agir à
l'échelle européenne mais évidemment
tout appel et tout soutien des députés
des sénateurs il y a eu notamment au
Sénat une mission d'information sur le
sujet extrêmement précieuse comme on l'a
vu notamment avec la loi avia qui est
quand même aussi à l'origine DJs donc
nous serons prêts à travailler avec tous
les députés intéressés par ce sujet et
je crois que nombre d'entre vous déjà
autour de véritable ont déjà eu
l'occasion d'échanger avec les membres
de la FFT nous serons ravis de
poursuivre ces échanges je vous remercie
madame Chikirou pour le groupe la France
insoumise
la question technique du raccordement à
la fibre on pose en réalité la question
de pratique de l'accès à Internet qui
aujourd'hui indispensable au quotidien
des Français la fracture numérique dans
notre pays c'est un Français sur trois
qui a soit un problème d'accès soit un
problème de de d'utilisation c'est pas
une fracture générationnelle seulement
c'est aussi et beaucoup social et
territorial j'y reviendrai un peu plus
tard vous êtes satisfait et on l'a
entendu ce matin d'avoir techniquement
presque atteint les objectifs
quantitatifs du déploiement de la fibre
parce qu'au niveau qualitatif on est en
droit de vous questionner parce qu'on
tout cela ressemble finalement à une
innovation à deux vitesses le réseau
cuivre voué à disparaître n'est plus
entretenu on voit des habitants privés
de service pendant des mois entiers
comme ce fut le cas dans le Calvados
récemment le raccordement à la fibre non
plus n'est pas bon les opérations de
raccordement sont mal faites il y a des
dysfonctionnements un abaissement de
service historiquement c'était orange
qui assuré l'homogénéité la qualité du
réseau sur le territoire on a voulu
aller vite très vite plus vite pour moi
cher au prix de l'exclusion finalement
du million de nos concitoyens qui sont
laissés pour compte peut-être 10 %
seulement mais c'est énorme surtout
quand c'est toujours sur les mêmes que
ça porte vous faites vite et mal je suis
désolé de le dire comme ça vous avez
bénéficié de la mensuétude de l'Autorité
de régulation des communications
électroniques avec les fameuses
dérogations stocks qui sont de la
sous-traitance à l'opérateur commercial
finalement ce qui devait être
l'exception est devenu la règle et 75%
des opérations qui présentent des
défauts sont dus à la sous-traitance
donc quelle mesure avez-vous d'ores et
déjà engagé contre le recours abusif à
la sous-traitance le Sénat vient de
légiférer c'est la PPL chaise allez-vous
oui ou non prendre vos responsabilités
dans cette chaîne donc allez-vous
stopper moi je le dis très clairement
allez vous stoppez arrêtez de supprimer
des postes en interne allez vous
recruter allez-vous investir dans la
formation professionnelle allez-vous
mettre assumer des devoirs les devoirs
qui sont les autres parce qu'on vous a
entendu parler de vos droits vous avez
des droits à faire du profit vous avez
des droits à tirer profit des décisions
politiques qui sont prises par le
gouvernement vous vendez aujourd'hui par
exemple beaucoup de neufs alors qu'on
devrait entrer dans un cycle de
reconditionnement donc déco conception
des produits est-ce que vous êtes prêts
à prendre vos responsabilités dans ce
domaine aussi écologique et
environnemental vous parlez des
investissements que vous avez fait mais
vous avez augmenté le prix des
abonnements 20% en un an vous avez
augmenté vos marges donc ces
investissements sont justifiés vous
pouvez pas vous plaindre de faire des
investissements et en même temps
d'augmenter vos profits d'augmenter les
tarifs donc des droits oui des devoirs
assumer les et de bonnes façons merci
merci beaucoup alors en une minute 15
qui souhaiterait répondre allez-y madame
ou quelqu'un d'autre qui souhaiterait
répondre n'hésitez pas une minute 15
très très rapidement
je vous rappelle que le modèle de
déploiement et les attentes de l'Arcelle
du régulateur de l'État ont été
extrêmement importantes et donc on a dû
faire des déploiements massifs
effectivement dans des délais qui
n'avaient jamais été vus aucun réseau
n'a jamais été déployé dans le monde
aussi vite et aussi rapidement
aujourd'hui la France est numéro 1 donc
on a pris nos responsabilités évidemment
qu'on a dû sous-traiter s'appuyer
d'ailleurs sur une sous-traitance de
qualité je le redis non non
laissez-moi laissez-moi laissez-moi
juste parler je dis pas de qualité au
niveau des intervenants je parle au
niveau c'est ce sont des professionnels
du BTP sur lequel on s'adressant en
s'adressant en s'adressant aux
entreprises de Dean qui était les
structures on a développé de l'emploi en
France d'accord on a développé de
l'emploi on leur a demandé de déployer
très massivement et très rapidement pour
répondre aux engagements sous menaces
parfois de sanctions très sévère du
régulateur si on atteignait pas un
certain nombre de jalons et vous savez
qu'il y a eu des contentieux qui ont
d'ailleurs été perdus sur cette
thématique là donc on a dû déployer très
rapidement dans une première phase pour
atteindre ces fameux jalons ces jalons
étaient atteints aujourd'hui
effectivement il faut reprendre cette
qualité je le redis il faut refaire tout
ce que on vous a décrit en intervenant
en refaisant un certain nombre
d'interventions vous nous avez parlé
d'engagement RSE nous avons tous pris
des engagements RSE effectivement pour
diminuer les impacts environnementaux
des réseaux nous nous mettons à
disposition de nos clients aussi pour
qu'il diminuent et je vais juste dire
une chose une dernière chose sur les
augmentations de tarif nous n'avons pas
augmenté nos tarifs de 20%, nous sommes
un secteur qui est
déflationniste en période d'inflation
merci Monsieur kata je vous propose de
passer à Virginie dubimuler du groupe LR
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente messieurs il y a 10 ans le
gouvernement déployait le plan France
très haut débit un plan d'investissement
massif pour que l'ensemble du territoire
français soit couvert par la fibre
optique et qui a permis de rendre plus
de 80 % des Français à cordables à la
fibre optique en 2022 il y a 5 ans
l'ARCEP et le gouvernement annonçait un
New Deal mobile pour réduire la fracture
numérique mobile en s'appuyant notamment
sur des pylônes mutualisés entre les
opérateurs cette stratégie a permis à la
France de combler son retard et de
devenir un vrai champion du Haut Débit
grâce à l'action de l'État des
collectivités territoriales et de
l'ARCEP pourtant force de constater que
de nombreux dysfonctionnements
persistent tant chez les particuliers
que chez les professionnels dans ma
circonscription je suis très souvent
interpellée sur le manque de débit
internet autant dans les zones rurales
qu'urbaines qui se sentent complètement
délaissés sur le plan numérique alors où
les usages ont évolué notamment le
télétravail il est inimaginable pour nos
concitoyens de ne pas avoir un accès à
un réseau très haut débit et sans
compter les dérives liées à
l'installation de la fibre avec certains
techniciens qui n'hésitent pas à
demander de l'argent en espèces pour
poursuivre les malfaçons les
raccordements ratés et autres des
branchements sauvages d'abonnés sur les
réseaux de fibres la partie en RIP de la
Haute-Savoie fait d'ailleurs partie des
eaux ayant un taux de panne et d'échecs
de raccordement parmi les plus élevés le
sénateur Patrick chaise a fait adopter à
l'unanimité une proposition de loi
visant à assurer la qualité la pérennité
des réseaux de communication
électronique à très haut débit en fibre
optique pensez-vous que ce texte soit
une bonne réponse au blocage actuel
pensez-vous que le mode stock soit
encore le plus adapté étant donné les
dysfonctionnements précédemment évoqués
en 2020 une nouvelle feuille de route
élaborée par la filière a conduit un
nouveau modèle de contrat de
sous-traitance qu'elle procès avez-vous
mis en place pour répondre à ses
objectifs comment améliorer la qualité
des interventions et leur traçabilité
par ailleurs alors que les opérateurs
télécoms sont des acteurs centraux dans
cette stratégie de déploiement des
réseaux des freins ou des mesures de
blocage demeure pour parvenir à une
complétude de la couverture du
territoire quelle mesure législatives
pourrait parachever la couverture mobile
du territoire et réduire les délais de
déploiement à quelle contrainte
réglementaire environnemental ou en
matière d'urbanisme êtes-vous encore
soumis je vous remercie
je vous remercie qui souhaiterait
répondre allez-y alors sur les
déploiements je vais commencer par là
c'est très rapide donc il y a les
dispositions sur la loi littorale donc
notamment la proposition loi de Monsieur
battu d'autres propositions de loi qui
ont été déposées qui vont dans le bon
sens puisqu'il y a 1700 sites
potentiellement bloqués il y a pas
seulement les littoral toute la Bretagne
notamment mais aussi toute la côte ouest
le sud il y a aussi notamment la Savoie
où il y a des lacs qui sont soumis à la
loi littorale pour vous donner juste un
exemple dans le Morbihan 144 sites
potentiellement bloqués l'approbation la
loi Elan sur la proposition loi stocke
il y a un vrai sujet sur quelques
réseaux atypiques donc la présidente de
la recette l'a dit 0,12% de SAV qui
doivent être traités mais il y a des
réseaux dans lesquels il y a beaucoup
beaucoup d'accident que la moyenne
notamment celui que vous avez cité le
rip en Savoie donc sur ces réseaux très
clairement il faut des plans de reprise
ces plans de reprise sont pris est-ce
qu'il faut changer la méthode pour 1% du
parc il faut absolument traiter sur du
parc sur lesquels se concentrent les
difficultés c'est notre priorité c'est
notre impératif et ce qu'il faut changer
les règles alors que sur le reste du
parc sur 99% du parc le taux de SAV de
0,12%. je vous réponds à la place de
tous les opérateurs ici et on en a
longuement discuté il ne faut pas
changer ce plan qui marche avec 14000
raccordement par jour c'est pas en
faisant un jeu de chaise musicale qu'on
change le problème de toute façon que ce
soit les opérateurs d'infrastructures ou
les opérateurs commerciaux ce serait les
mêmes intervenants sur le terrain par
contre on est sûr que ça ne fonctionnera
pas parce que ça doublerait
mécaniquement les délais de raccordement
aujourd'hui il y a un seul intervenant
qui peut à la fois aller au point de
mutualisation et raccorder le client
avec un changement de méthode sera sa
doublera mécaniquement les délais et
donc ça fera monter l'insatisfaction des
clients ce double aussi les capacités
nécessaires et sa perturberait
complètement l'économie de la filière
puisque aujourd'hui les sous-traitants
ils ont quatre interlocuteurs ils en
auraient une centaine ce serait
ingérable en termes de systèmes
d'information
et de gestion des processus merci
beaucoup je vous propose de passer à
Madame Luis Morel du groupe modem
quelqu'un peut fermer son micro
quelqu'un doit avoir un micro ouvert
allez-y c'est bon merci monsieur le
Président chers collègues madame
messieurs au nom du groupe démocrate je
tiens à vous remercier pour votre
présence devant notre commission ce
matin les usages numériques font partie
intégrante de notre quotidien et il est
essentiel que la représentation
nationale puisse régulièrement
rencontrer les acteurs du secteur en
2023 il est également indispensable que
tous les citoyens aient accès à un
réseau numérique de qualité c'est
pourquoi il a été décidé de remplacer
progressivement le réseau cuivre par un
réseau de fibre optiques à horizon 2030
la fibre optique offre de meilleures
performances que le cuivre tout en étant
moins énergivore et sont déploiement
permettra aux citoyen de bénéficier d'un
réseau numérique de meilleure qualité
votre travail dans la réussite de ce
pari est à salué toutefois il existe en
2023 des territoires qui ne bénéficient
d'aucun raccordement au réseau
performant ni le cuivre ni la fibre les
habitants des territoires concernés ils
subissent une véritable fracture
numérique pour prendre l'exemple du
département du Bas-Rhin où je suis l'une
des députés malgré un équipement
satisfaisant 3% du histoire et en zone
blanche 10% en zone grise et malgré les
efforts réalisés ces zones restent
délaissées ma question est la suivante
quelles sont les freins qui expliquent
ce non raccordement est-ce des raisons
géographiques juridiques financières
autre et quelle solution peuvent être
apportées et deuxièmement nous l'avons
déjà un petit peu évoqué le sujet des
raccordements effectué par les
sous-traitants ma question elle porte
plus précisément sur les contrastes V2
c'est un plan d'action référentiel mais
est-il suffisant pour limiter les
débordements lors des installations et
sinon comment l'améliorer je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup qui souhaite
prendre la réponse
ne vous battez pas
elle aimerait vous laisser nos invités
pourtant elle a été effectivement
remarquable donc qui va monsieur
secrétaire général c'est juste le on a
pas bien compris vous parlez de zone
blanche fixe et mobile ou mobil-oufix
la première c'est comment on fait dans
des zones qui sont à la fois blanche
puis grise globalement pour être
accordée et c'est quoi les véritables
obstacles moi je suis pas dans une zone
littorale je suis dans le département du
Bas-Rhin donc est-ce que c'est vraiment
parfois des sujets techniques type
géographiques ou juridique ou autre et
mon autre question c'est j'ai vu
puisqu'on parle les raccordements le
sujet des contrats stock V2 qui sont
censés encadrer un petit peu ces sujets
de sous-traitance en termes de
raccordement et ce qu'il faut
l'améliorer ou non ce cadre de
contractuels V2 je crois que le contrat
c'est pas une fin en soi en fait ils ont
déjà été améliorés avec des systèmes de
pénalité on a rediscuté ces contrats on
les a aussi on a aussi discuté la partie
sous-traitance pour les simplifier pour
les simplifier donc je pense que c'est
pas l'outil contractuel en fait qu'il
faut c'est repartir du terrain regarder
les problèmes concrets qu'on a sur le
terrain et les régler un par un avec nos
sous-traitants entre opérateurs
commerciaux entre opérateurs
infrastructures sans se renvoyer la
balle mais en regardant très
concrètement quels sont les problèmes
qu'on doit régler et c'est aussi pour ça
que la PPL avec tout le respect que j'ai
pour Patrick chaise ne règle pas ça une
loi ne peut pas régler ça aujourd'hui on
est face à des malfaçons on est face à
des problèmes de terrain il faut les
régler sur le terrain sous le contrôle
du régalateur sous le contrôle du
législateur au sens de vos commissions
tout à fait ça on est parfait mais il
faut le traiter sur le terrain et pas
par un texte générique qui regardez on a
parlé des quatre dispositions des quatre
problèmes qu'on rencontrait à la pépel
ne règle aucun des les réseaux atypiques
sont pas abordés par la PPL les réseaux
les plats de nouilles sont pas abordés
évidemment qui ne peuvent pas les
abordés la question de la sous-traitance
n'est pas abordée ne peut pas être
abordée etc etc donc il faut traiter ça
sur le terrain sur votre première
question qui était sur la couverture la
couverture mobile en fait
les les
efforts de déploiement entre entre le
plan très haut débit avec cette idée
d'atteindre en 2025 effectivement une
couverture de 85 de 80% toute zone avec
des technologies alternatives etc et le
mobile on est sur des niveaux de
couverture qui sont en progression
permanent qui sont extraordinairement
importants il n'y a pas de blocage
générique absolu d'un claquement de
doigts qui qui permettrait de régler le
sujet là encore il faut regarder très
concrètement cas par cas on a parlé par
exemple sur la fibre des raccordements
complexes c'est quelque chose qui va
falloir traiter les raccordements de
domaine privé il va falloir les traiter
aussi merci beaucoup je vous propose de
passer à Monsieur Philippe n'ayez le
groupe socialiste
si monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues les députés socialistes
apparentés tiennent rappeler l'important
c'est la responsabilité des opérateurs
que vous représentez bien sûr pour la
transition numérique de notre pays bien
sûr pour l'intérêt général la fibre
optique ça a été dit avant moi
représentent des enjeux sociaux
économiques démocratiques en termes de
développement économique pour nos
entreprises face à une concurrence
internationale dans laquelle
l'innovation technologique et la
compétitivité son créatrice d'emploi et
conditionne et conditionné par la
numérisation des usages pour la vitalité
de nos territoires ça a été dit
également la fracture numérique a des
conséquences importantes pour un nombre
conséquent nos concitoyens souvent les
plus précaires avec des conséquences en
termes d'accès aux droits d'égalité des
chances pour me citer que ces situations
là nous déplorons donc la lenteur de son
déploiement jusqu'aux raccordement de
toutes et tous dans un monde
interconnecté être connecté par la fibre
optique ou non France accéder au nom
très haut débit au nom de nos
concitoyens c'est tout simplement être
relié au monde ou en être
nous constatons surtout et c'est un
euphémisme une certaine désorganisation
qui déconcertent une partie de la
population et c'est en cela que vous
avez une responsabilité chacun d'entre
vous mais également collectivement la
sous-traitance en cascade n'est pas une
bonne chose loin de là à quelques
kilomètres d'ici des tableaux de
raccordement indescriptible des salariés
qui se retrouvent dépourvus dans des
situations conflictuelles que au final
porte préjudice à tout le monde des
habitants qui attendent des semaines
d'être dépanner du fait de raccordement
sauvage ou mal réalisé il est temps que
vous preniez vos responsabilités
d'opérateurs sont quoi je le dis nous
serions obligés bien sûr d'user de notre
prérogative de légis législative ma
question elle est très simple quelle
disposition comptez-vous prendre enfin
je voudrais attirer votre attention sur
la situation particulière des
territoires ultramarins étant moi-même
député de La Réunion je dois souligner
que pour ce qui concerne la Réunion bien
que perfectible dans le cas du
déploiement de la fibre optique nous
n'avons pas été maltraités je me dois
néanmoins de rappeler que nos
territoires pour la plupart isolés
géographiquement doivent bénéficier de
conditions nécessaires à leur
développement au sein de leur bassin
géographique c'est un enjeu majeur pour
nous merci
merci qui souhaite prendre monsieur Ali
merci merci
j'aimerais revenir sur un de vos points
que vous avez mentionné qui concerne la
lenteur du déploiement aujourd'hui la
France fait partie des champions
d'Europe du déploiement on a dépouillé
sur 80% du pays en moins de 10 ans on ne
peut pas parler de 20h on peut
probablement parler de certains
problèmes certains dysfonctionnements
certaines malfaçons comme vous l'avez
souligné les les plats de nouilles les
problèmes de raccordement on en a bien
conscience mais on ne peut pas parler de
lenteur ça c'est c'est la première la
première chose maintenant qu'est-ce que
nous faisons qu'est-ce que nous avons
commencé à mettre en place justement
pour régler ses dysfonctionnements
aussi bien Isaac Nicolas l'ont déjà
rappelé il y a des plans filaires qui
ont été qui ont été mis en place depuis
le deuxième semestre 2022 ça passe par
un une réduction importante du Range
sous-traitance ça passe par la
certification la labellisation des
entreprises qui interviennent sur le
terrain pour les raccordements sa place
ça passe par la mise en place de partage
de planning d'intervention
la mise en place de de partage de
de compte rendu d'intervention
ça passe aussi comme on l'a évoqué par
la reprise de réseau atypique orange on
a repris nous en reprenons d'autres
opérateurs d'infrastructures en
reprennent
par conséquent nous prenons nos
responsabilités nos responsabilités
les outils sont là nous les avons mis en
place avec la filière
nous avons besoin de temps
pour finaliser et corriger ces malfaçons
mais les outils sont là et nous les
appliquons merci beaucoup merci je vous
propose de passer à Monsieur Luc lamiro
ou horizon c'était vous merci monsieur
le Président Madame et Messieurs mes
chers collègues la fibre optique à la
monnaie est une très belle technologie
l'engouement qu'elle suscite nous oblige
à être tous mobilisés pour une
installation rapide il me faut pose il
ne faut cependant pas confondre rapidité
et précipice
précipitations et j'ai l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui nous nous retrouvons plus
dans la précipitation
elles génèrent chez certains d'entre
vous une grande mobilisation afin de
gagner des parts de marché et c'est
notre chez notre opérateur historique
propriétaire du réseau filaire un
abandon de ce dernier pendant ce temps
nous récupérons dans nos permanences vos
clients dépités beaucoup d'entre eux
nous sollicitent sur le mauvais
entretien de ce qu'il considère comme un
bien commun car construit à l'époque par
la puissance publique je veux bien sûr
parler du réseau cuivre l'état
déplorable des poteaux de nos poteaux
fait mal avoir les fils qui pendent les
poteaux cassés et j'en passe nos
concitoyens ne comprennent pas la
négligence dont orange fait preuve
heureusement pour nombre de vos usagers
il ne s'agit que d'une inquiétude car
leur ligne fonctionne encore mais quand
la panar arrive le calvaire commence et
la tente surtout
je veux témoigner ici de l'inquiétude de
nos concitoyens ma première question
vous l'avez compris sera pour Orange
vous avez récupéré une propriété
publique ne vous sentez-vous pas
redevable de la maintenir en l'état
parlons désormais de la fibre puisque
vous êtes tous présents comme j'ai dit
précédemment nous avons une obligation
commune de tout mettre en oeuvre pour la
mettre en place pour mettre en place ce
service à notre population
pensez-vous cependant que cela puisse se
faire en respectant les câbles de
raccordement dans les fameuses chambres
Love en évitant que les jarretières
fassent des pelotes ou même soient
pincées en surveillant l'état des points
de mutualisation des tiroirs cassés sont
nombreux en s'assurant du bon entretien
des points de branchement optique
ce sont les incidents les plus fréquents
qui me sont remontés dû me semble-t-il à
la multiplication des sous-traitants de
haut de vos grandes fonctions vous allez
me dire que tout a été mis en œuvre pour
améliorer la qualité là aussi je
souhaite témoigner que vos équipes n'y
sont pas encore arrivés vos promesses de
belles qualités de meilleure qualité ne
se voit pas sur le terrain vous l'avez
compris je suis de ceux qui pensent que
nous devrons légiférer pour une
meilleure organisation à moins d'un
rebond de votre part je suis ici pour
être convaincu par vous merci
qui souhaite répondre une question
directe
pas sur le cul mais c'est là je peux y
répondre quand même en fait d'abord le
réseau cuit effectivement est un réseau
qu'on a déployé ce sont nos agents dont
certains sont encore là qu'ils l'ont
déployé dans les à partir des années 70
et dans les années qui ont qui ont suivi
donc on est on est conscient et très
[Musique]
véritablement conscient de l'importance
de cette qualité de service maintenant
il y a une réalité économique aussi une
réalité de réseau qui est que les coûts
d'exploitation d'entretien de ce réseau
ont augmenté de 37%, c'est les dernières
années on continue à maintenir les
budgets sur de moins en moins de limes
et les mêmes budgets que qu'on a
consacré c'est plus de 500 millions de
d'euros d'entretien par année sur le
réseau cuivre on en est notre sixième
plan cuivre de rattrapage de la qualité
de service en permanence mais il y a une
réalité ce réseau effectivement et de
plus en plus vieux il vieillit mal il a
de plus en plus de panne donc ça je peux
déjà vous réaffirmer ces éléments là ça
ces éléments et on a un problème
économique mais sur lequel je ne
reviendrai pas plus amplement qui est
qu'effectivement on nous dit ce réseau
est le réseau d'Orange mais ce réseau le
coût de ce réseau doit être partagé le
coût de l'entretien de ce réseau doit
être partagé j'en dirai pas plus à ce
stade là et je renvoie ma proposition du
du début sur la deuxième partie qui est
la la
multiplication des sous-traitants et le
je veux revenir je vais en profiter pour
revenir sur ce que dit tout à l'heure en
fait on a limité effectivement le rang
de le nombre de rangs de sous-traitants
et on l'a fait appel à des
sous-traitants de rang 1 qui sont des
spécialistes du marché et on travaille
en permanence avec eux dans le cadre des
contrats qu'on a avec eux pour
effectivement améliorer sur le terrain
on a introduit dans les contrats des
pénalités effectivement sur la
sous-traitant on contrôle de plus en
plus leurs activités mais mon propos
tout à l'heure vous méprenez pas c'est
je voudrais pas non plus qu'on tombe
dans un système de bashing des
sous-traitants on a 2000 techniciens qui
ne sont pas qui nous manquent sur le
terrain qui nous manque sur le terrain
aussi donc il faut trouver il faut en
améliorant en améliorant la qualité de
service en travaillant avec tout ce
traitant il faut qu'on puisse aussi
pouvoir continuer à recourir à employer
à attirer des gens vers ces métiers là
sinon on aura un énorme merci beaucoup
je ne doute pas que vous serez interrogé
tout à l'heure individuellement par
d'autres députés sur le sujet et
comprendre le temps d'y répondre je vous
propose de passer de terminer la série
des orateurs groupes avec Paul Molac du
groupe Yot
merci monsieur le Président bonjour à
tous donc moi j'avais quelques questions
directement donc on a alors en fonction
des régions il y a des choix qui ont été
différents par exemple en Bretagne on a
décidé que ce serait 100% des foyers qui
seraient raccordés à la fibre dans
certains régions ces 80 % des foyers
ceux qui peuvent faire 50% du territoire
qu'est-ce qui est prévu pour pour les
autres parce qu'évidemment il y a des
gens qui habitent aussi dans ces zones
là et donc j'aimerais vous entendre
là-dessus
sur
les alors effectivement nous on doit
avoir les problèmes de complétude en
Bretagne le problème doit être autour de
3% quelque chose comme ça mais il y a
certaines régions effectivement on
arrive à 15% et donc ça pose un problème
et dans ces cas-là est-ce que le
raccordement c'est-à-dire les 100 mètres
voire un peu plus qui restent sont à la
charge de l'opérateur commercial je
suppose pour l'instant en tout cas c'est
le cas est-ce que ça va le rester
et puis dernière chose sur
oui alors quelquefois sur les
raccordements il y a effectivement des
sommes qui peuvent être importantes
parce que par exemple je vais prendre un
exemple clair quelqu'un où on est obligé
de creuser finalement dans un cours ça
ces sommes là sont bien pris en compte
par l'opérateur commercial
c'est alors c'est là où
il faut qu'on trouve quelque chose parce
qu'effectivement ça peut ça peut il peut
y avoir des sommes très importantes
et puis j'avais une autre question oui
pour l'instant c'est offert l'opérateur
commercial oui bon ce sera tout et ben
c'est déjà bien monsieur voilà qui
souhaite répondre à un peu plus de 2
minutes monsieur c'est un général
allez-y et puis sur le micro c'est bon
donc effectivement le votre première
question elle porte sur une réalité en
France qui est qui a 5 zones de
déploiement avec des règles de dépamment
différentes la zone très dense la zone
amie la zone Amel et les zoneries les
zoneries les zones donc nous on jongle
effectivement avec un outil industriel
qui doit passer d'une zone à l'autre
toutes les faire avec un objectif de 80%
THD en 2025 donc plus on nous met la
pression sur une zone plus on est obligé
de prendre des effectifs et avec les
2000 personnes qui nous manquent encore
sur le terrain aujourd'hui plus on est
obligé de les prendre d'une zone pour
les mettre sur une autre zone on est en
permanence en train de rééquilibrer de
rééquilibrer en oubliant qu'une zone
toutes les zones ont continué à être
déployer la zone très dense la zone amie
les zoneries donc en ce moment ce qu'on
essaie c'est vraiment de faire porter
les forces sur les zones
mais la zone amie peut interpeller ce
dispositif avec les procédures dont j'ai
participé tout à l'heure et les risques
qu'on a de sanctions pécuniaires sur la
zone amie alors que la zone tendance
elle est plus concurrentielle la zone
RIP est réglée par les contrats avec les
collectivités la zone amène est une
intermédiaire entre entre les deux donc
on essaie de jongler en permanence sont
aussi différentes ces différentes zones
et les déploiements ce que vous avez
signalé effectivement c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure on a un vrai
énorme travail à faire effectivement sur
ces raccordements complexes ces quelques
pourcents qui restent avec deux
problématiques le raccordement les
derniers mètres sur la zone publique qui
est pour aller jusqu'au bornes du
terrain voilà et puis le raccordement
privé donc on a des débats en ce moment
avec le gouvernement sur cette
thématique pour voir effectivement il y
a des fonds publics qui ont été
effectivement prévu un des orateurs tout
à l'heure le rappelait ils sont pas
encore totalement affectés donc il faut
sans doute réformer la façon dont on les
met à disposition parce qu'ils ne sont
pas libérés assez vite notamment pour
permettre de financer les raccordements
complexes en zone privée de nos
concitoyens qui peuvent être amenés à
faire effectivement
le maître de trancher à leurs frais pour
raccorder et puis il y a cette question
du raccordement en zone publique sur
lequel là encore il peut y avoir des
coûts extraordinairement important à
prendre en charge donc on est en train
d'en débattre entre opérateurs et avec
le gouvernement pour trouver des
solutions parce que il faudra faire ses
lignes alors peut-être pas les lignes
450000 euros j'exagère ou là il y a des
solutions alternatives qui devront être
mises en œuvre et là aussi on en parle
avec le régulateur on redit le satellite
est une solution je parle satellites de
nouvelles générations je parle pas des
peut-être des satellites que vous avez
connus et puis de la 4G fixe de la 5G
fixe
merci beaucoup je vous propose
maintenant de passer aux questions
individuelles n'hésitez pas à lever la
main pour qu'on puisse vous identifier
correctement alors le principe est
simple on prend toutes les questions
c'est une minute maximum sur chacune des
questions et puis à la fin vous répondez
à l'ensemble des interpellations que
vous avez reçu je vous propose de
commencer tout de suite avec Monsieur
Antoine Armand on y va merci monsieur le
Président je vais je vais simplement
relayer finalement ce que ce que mes
collègues disent depuis tout à l'heure
puisque dans cette commission ce matin
sur tous les bancs et de tous les bords
politiques les questions sont très
proches et je crois qu'à ce stade nous
n'avons pas eu les réponses que nous
avons demandé vous parler à juste titre
de pourcentage nous parlons de nombres
nous parlons de cas concrets je relai
l'inquiétude de ma collègue de
Haute-Savoie c'est 145 dégradations en
quelques mois ce sont des excréments
dans les locaux ce sont des serrures
jamais réparés faute de moyens
puisqu'elles sont cassées quasiment tous
les jours ce sont des techniciens qui ne
peuvent pas faire le travail ou qui ne
le font manifestement pas je plus
personne j'ai conscience de l'effort qui
a été fait dans le déploiement de la
fibre qui est indispensable qui est
porté par le gouvernement et qui
réalisait opérationnellement par vous
mais vous ne pouvez pas nous dire que
vous prenez vos responsabilités et que
les choses sont faites puisque
manifestement quotidiennement ce n'est
pas le cas donc est-ce que vous pourriez
être un peu plus précis dans les
responsabilités que vous prenez et dans
les actions urgentes indispensables
nécessaires que vous mènerez je n'en
doute pas dans les tous prochains mois
et nous vous invitons bien sûr
cordialement je pense avec ma collègue à
venir en Haute-Savoie si vous avez
besoin de constater ce que je dis merci
beaucoup monsieur delapino
merci monsieur le président madame
messieurs moi je voudrais mettre sur la
scène maintenant d'Homère qui sont
confrontés quotidiennement au
récrimination de leurs concitoyens du
fait d'être différents
dysfonctionnements que nous avons déjà
évoqué entre autres ces fameuses
armoires vandalisées
il est tout d'abord étonnant qu'en
termes de d'ingénierie il n'est pas été
conçu des boîtes de raccordement
sécurisés il s'agit d'une très haute
technologie et on voit qu'en réalité on
est resté sur des armoires
identiques à celles que l'on utilisait
pour le cuivre ça c'est la première
observation deuxième observation les
maires aujourd'hui sont obligés de
prendre des arrêtés pour que des amendes
soient infligées aux opérateurs qui ne
préviennent pas de leur intervention
pour éviter d'avoir Pierre Paul ou
Jacques pas forcément agréé pour
intervenir se présenter ouvrir une
armoire et en règle générale oublier de
la fermer et moi je suis député de
Vaucluse le mistral soul souffle très
fort et je vous garantis qu'il est
beaucoup plus puissant pour démonter les
armoires qui comptent
ne sont pas les moyens de financier de
changer tous ces équipements merci je
vous remercie je propose de passer à
Monsieur Vincent Roland
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Halimi tout à l'heure vous avez dit ne
pas minimiser les problèmes mais les
résoudre et bien il y a de quoi faire XP
fibre qui fibre dans la cadre de la
procédure Amel le département de la
Savoie ne respectent pas grand chose ni
les infrastructures des enrobés tout
neufs défoncé pour passer la fibre sans
coordination avec les maisons du
territoire technique
non respect de la sécurité je tiens
votre disposition une photo ou un
opérateur intervient dans une chambre à
quatre pattes dans un virage sur une
route départementale et non respect du
cahier des charges puisqu'une partie est
fibrée en aérien alors que cela est
prévu en souterrain quel remède de
cheval si je peux me permettre
proposez-vous pour effacer
tous ces dysfonctionnements
merci beaucoup je vous propose de passer
à Monsieur romain Daubié
la parole dans cette quête dans le cadre
de ces tables rondes avec les opérateurs
télécom je salue représentant des
l'ensemble des opérateurs et en
particulier même béludo que j'avais eu
le plaisir de recevoir au conseil
départemental de l'Ain et pour
l'inauguration d'une antenne 5G dans mon
canton de Meximieux Montluel aujourd'hui
il y a un vrai sujet de fracture
numérique dont de nombreux territoires
dont le mien département de l'Ain que ça
soit pour l'accès à la fibre et
également à un réseau téléphonique qui
fonctionne la réponse technique vu de la
recette on nous dit bah à Paris sur
notre ordinateur de tableau Excel votre
zone n'est pas blanche est une réponse
technique qui n'est pas acceptable et
aujourd'hui on a un problème de rapidité
du déploiement donc j'aimerais savoir ce
qui pour vous peut être fait pour
accélérer la
réduction de la fracture numérique et
j'aimerais une autre réponse que la
suppression de l'ifère ce que c'est une
recette dynamique importante pour notre
la collectivité de l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales je vous
remercie merci beaucoup je vous propose
de passer à Monsieur Thierry Benoît
merci monsieur le Président pour Orange
concernant le la maintenance du réseau
cuivre d'ici à 2030 et le basculement à
la fibre est-ce que vous pourriez pas
mettre en place une procédure d'urgence
qui permettrait aux maires ou au
parlementaire dans les départements
d'apporter des solutions immédiates et
rapides à des situations d'urgence je
pense à des personnes âgées équipées de
télé Alam qui sont parfois qu'un jour
trois semaines un mois deux mois sans
téléphone deuxième point pour l'ensemble
des opérateurs qu'ils soient commerciaux
ou d'infrastructure est-ce que vous ne
pourriez pas vous mettre d'accord vous
êtes des grandes entreprises vous n'êtes
que quatre sur le territoire national
convenir d'accord pour installer
déployer les antennes relais dans les
territoires il est incompréhensible que
l'on trouve des pylônes à 100 mètres 200
m 3 4 pylônes vous vous battez vous vous
bagarez vous empoisonner qui dériverai
des élus locaux alors que vous pourriez
très bien vous mettre d'accord dernier
point concernant la créditation des
entreprises des sous-traitants
accréditer les sous-traitants c'est une
chose est-ce que il y a un programme de
formation des agents qui déploient la
fibre dans les territoires merci merci
beaucoup je vous propose de passer à
Jean-Pierre Vigier
oui merci monsieur le Président avec
l'essor du télétravail l'accès au
service public et puis d'un otage
quotidiennes la fibre optique est
aujourd'hui essentielle pour beaucoup de
Français or le déploiement des réseaux
de cette fibre souffre de dysfonction
dysfonctionnement particulièrement fort
en zone rurale à titre d'exemple avec
une sous-traitance en cascade et
peut-être pour réduire le coût on ne
sait pas on ne sait plus qui intervient
et quand et dans certains cas le travail
est très mal fait et il faut recommencer
deuxième point dans certains cas
certains entreprises interviennent dans
des communes et le maire n'est même pas
prévenu et quand il est questionné par
ses administrés il ne s'est pas répandre
et encore heureusement que nous les élus
nous avons des contacts locaux auprès de
certains opérateurs qui nous donnent des
réponses à la FFT on est toujours bien
reçu et on nous donne toujours des
bonnes réponses précises mais Madame et
Messieurs quelle solution pouvez-vous
apporter à ces problèmes récurrent et
dernier point à quand un réseau Bouygues
Telecom correct en milieu rural car
depuis que l'Assemblée nationale a
changé d'opérateur pour nous c'est
catastrophique merci merci beaucoup je
vous propose de passer à Dominique
Pottier
et merci monsieur le président
quand on regarde sur la longue histoire
l'histoire de l'eau potable l'histoire
des télécoms dans notre pays on peut
dire que la libéralisation du marché
elle démontre son incapacité à
performance qu'on a connu avec moins de
finances publiques moins de moyens nos
aînés ont su déployés des réseaux de
façon républicaine universelle avec
beaucoup moins de désordre que ce qu'on
constate aujourd'hui avec des citoyens
des salariés maltraités même si il faut
relativiser et souligner la performance
de la France en matière de déploiement
de la fibre par rapport à d'autres pays
européens c'est désordre là nous amène à
repenser
à penser pour les corriger le besoin
d'une commande publique plus responsable
le besoin déployer le devoir de
vigilance y compris sur le territoire
national et européen et pas seulement de
leur rapport avec les pays tiers
concernant les sous-traitants et puis
l'importance des débats actuels au
niveau européen sur la reporting
extra-financier de la CSRP moi je crois
que vous interroger sur le partage de la
valeur entre les actionnaires et les
sous les salariés des sous-traitants
dont vous entreprises sur la qualité de
l'écoute et la déshumanisation de
l'accès aux services par les par les
citoyens et enfin sur la régulation de
la recette attendez l'article 4 de la
loi déposée au Sénat monsieur Gérardin
c'est à vous
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
madame messieurs je voudrais revenir sur
le sujet du choix des sous-traitants
monsieur Guérin vous nous avez dit tout
à l'heure que vous aviez choisi des
sous-traitants de rang 1 pour le
raccordement des abonnés à la fibre je
n'en doute pas sauf que je vais vous
expliquer le cas que j'ai eu avec le
raccordement de ma permanence
parlementaire qui est situé à Épernay au
cœur de ville où il y a le fibre qui
passe au pied du local et il y a eu 8
heures d'intervention pour raccorder
avec des gens qui balbutaient la
technique de manière très claire et qui
tenait des propos franchement qui était
assez incroyables en disant écoutez ce
qu'on vous fait ça ne tiendra jamais ça
va casser la fibre est de mauvaise
qualité je voulais juste vous le dire
parce que c'est franchement scandaleux
et c'est tombé sur moi tant mieux mais
je pense qu'ils l'ont fait auprès
d'autres abonnés qu'ils ont accordé et
franchement c'est contre-productif alors
que effectivement dans une région qui
est la région Grand Est où tout le monde
enfin les raccordements sont partout
puisque le président de la Région prend
plaisir à dire que la même un village où
il y a trois habitants et où
effectivement la fibre est arrivée donc
il y a une vraiment un écart incroyable
entre la performance et qui a été
l'installation et le résultat en termes
du coup je vous propose de passer à
Christine en grand c'est vous
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
représentants du opérateurs télécoms
dans un communiqué du 12 mars 2021
l'ARCEP se prononcée sur le mode stock
en ces termes il est difficilement
compréhensible que la qualité de service
sur les raccordements puisse être aussi
un site insatisfaisante dans certains
cas cette prise de parole intervenait un
nom après la mise en place d'une
limitation contractuelle au nombre de
rangs de deux sous-traitants à deux
maximum et plusieurs observateurs
dénoncés depuis que les derniers maîtres
de réseau raccordés au consommateur
final était souvent sous-traitée à
l'excès parfois jusqu'à 6 rangs
d'entreprise c'est le cas dans ma dans
ma circo circonscription puisque suite à
une tempête nous avons mis deux mois à
pouvoir récupérer j'allais dire une
connexion suffisante mais néanmoins
cette solution n'aurait pas rien résolu
puisque des associations comme la Vicat
souligne que le problème des malfaçons
est avant tout un problème de
rémunération des interventions des
techniciens les techniciens ne sont pas
assez rémunérés ça ne suffirait pas à
couvrir l'ensemble des dépenses induite
par la réglementation et nous aimerions
donc avoir votre opinion là dessus merci
merci beaucoup pour plus de passer à
Madame Sophia Chikirou
merci monsieur le Président bon avec la
numérisation à marche forcée qui a été
voulu par le gouvernement je crois que
vous avez pu en profiter et ça a été
même une aubaine pour vous je le dis
très clairement parce que finalement
aujourd'hui se pose la question de
l'accessibilité prix et il faut
sérieusement la poser vous dites non il
y a pas eu d'augmentation de 20%, moi je
dis que vous mentez en disant ça
monsieur il y a une augmentation des
tarifs de 20% sur l'année 2022 et vous
avez même justifié cela au prétexte des
investissements que vous avez fait au
prétexte des prix de l'énergie au
prétexte de l'augmentation des prix des
matières premières donc ma question est
très simple vous avez augmenté les prix
vous dites que tout ça c'était pour
payer donc je vous demande quel est le
montant des dividendes que vous allez
verser en 2023 à vos actionnaires est-ce
que cela va augmenter par rapport au
montant que vous avez versé en 2022 je
vous pose aussi la question de savoir
quelle est l'augmentation de salaire que
vous avez pratiqué en 2022 pour tous vos
employés sachant que par exemple SFR à
une grève au mois de décembre pour
demander des augmentations de salaire ma
question est donc très simple
merci beaucoup je vous propose de passer
à Monsieur Jérôme Nury c'est à vous
merci monsieur le président madame
messieurs les représentants des
opérateurs vous êtes en train de casser
la technologie fibre optique que nous
appelons tous de nos vœux car elle met
sur un même pied d'égalité les usagers
urbains et ruraux vous êtes en train de
casser le modèle de déploiement du FTTH
à la française association
publique et privées faisant regretter à
beaucoup de nos concitoyens le temps des
PTT de France Télécom vous êtes en train
de casser l'image même de cette
technologie par votre organisation
défaillante par votre communication
improbable et par vos défaillances et je
le dis tout à fait franchement aucun de
vous quatre ne fait mieux que les autres
nos concitoyens désespèrent et sont en
colère face aux problèmes rencontrés
pour les raccordements rendez-vous
annulé en permanence démarche
commerciale mensongères incompétence
pitoyable de vos sous-traitants qui
s'improvis spécialistes des réseaux
télécoms avec pioche et C15 breaks des
branchements intempestives des voisins
sur les pb ou sur les armoires tirage de
la fibre à partir des câbles cuivre qui
servent de tirgen et donc des branches
totalement les maisons absence totale
d'interlocuteurs pour les abonnés et les
clients sinon des centrales d'appel avec
des dépenses dignes de chaque gipiti
absence totale de correspondant pour les
élus face aux mécontentement de nos
concitoyens j'ai pas de question mais
une injonction réagissait
bougez-vous et revoyez vos méthodes il y
a urgence merci beaucoup je propose de
passer à Éric Bothorel
oui pour changer un peu et varier des
thèmes qui ont été abordés ce matin je
reviens sur le filtre entièrement qui a
un projet de loi qui a été présenté
maintenant il y a 15 jours tu connais
pas la date d'examen particulière et un
dispositif très attendu par nos
concitoyens qui permet des protéger des
cybercriminalité c'est le filtre anti
arnaque j'aurais aimé avoir votre retour
sur la façon dont vous accueillez le
dispositif tel qu'il a été pensé par le
gouvernement
merci beaucoup je vous propose de passer
à Monsieur Aurélien lopezigori
aujourd'hui vous êtes quatre opérateurs
autour de cette table frisé orange qui
déploie des antennes 5G Nokia donc
européenne et souveraine et Bouygues et
SFR qui ont fait le choix insensé de
Huawei pour leurs infrastructures pour
rappel Huawei est une entreprise
chinoise accusée d'espionnage est connu
pour ses liens avec le régime bref une
entreprise qui représente un véritable
risque pour les donner de nos
concitoyens et pour l'intérêt
fondamental de la nation en 2019
reconnaissant le risque le gouvernement
a interdit la 5G wawaii dans certaines
zones vous forçant à entamer un retrait
de mon infrastructures en Suède aux
États-Unis au Royaume-Uni ces états
démantèle la 5G huawaii sur l'ensemble
de leur territoire alors comment
justifier que vous continuez à déployer
ces antennes Huawei et cela contre toute
clairvoyance économique et surtout
contre toute moralité et chers collègues
je profite de cette tribune pour vous
annoncer que je vous ai envoyé une
proposition de loi visant à bannir la 5G
wawaii de France sur vos boîtes mail je
vous enjoins la cocignier parce que
notre souveraineté l'exige merci merci
beaucoup je propose de passer à Madame
Anne-Laure blanc
merci monsieur le président madame
messieurs merci d'être présent parce que
nous avons vraiment besoin d'avoir vos
explications parce que quand on vous
entend on a l'impression qu'à Paris tout
va bien mais dans les territoires rien
ne va les exemples des collègues sont
pas tant et touchent l'ensemble de nos
territoires ruraux la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons deux France
une France rurale une France urbaine une
France des territoires et une France
parisienne et la réalité aussi c'est que
les habitants ne comprennent pas ces
deux France ne comprennent pas cette
immobilisme des opérateurs de téléphonie
ne comprennent pas pourquoi aujourd'hui
au 21e siècle nous n'avons pas tous un
égal accès à la téléphonie j'ai connu il
y a quelques temps des coupures
intégrales dans des villages qui ont
duré un mois et demi j'ai dû intervenir
au plus haut niveau des opérateurs de
téléphonie pour que ces coupures soient
résolues aujourd'hui et il y a encore
quelques semaines ça a été à nouveau le
cas les durées d'intervention de
réparation sont énormes en dehors de
tout entendement quand on vit dans un
village coupé du monde qui pénalise qui
est pénalisée par une rupture d'égalité
aussi bien économique que pour la
sécurité des habitants parce que je
tiens à redire ici que des habitants
sont
une sécurité assurée grâce à un bracelet
qui est relié à des moyens de
téléphonique qui sont vitaux beaucoup je
vous propose de terminer avec Monsieur
André Villiers merci monsieur le
Président je veux évoquer l'abîme qui
subsiste parfois entre l'annonce des
politiques publiques et le quotidien de
nos concitoyens le dernier kilomètre
c'est son nom objet de l'étude actuelle
du Conseil d'État marque l'absolu
nécessité de la qualité du service rendu
notamment en milieu rural vous avez
madame et Messieurs sans doute fait
l'objet d'une audition dans cette
procédure qu'en est-il
y a-t-il d'autres questions
individuelles tout le monde a pu
s'exprimer pas de frustration très bien
je vous propose donc de vous donner la
parole pour une réponse à l'ensemble de
ces interpellations vous êtes totalement
libre donc vous pouvez tous vous
exprimer choisissez l'ordre l'idéal
serait qu'on arrive à terminer à 11h30
grand maximum donc on se donne 20
minutes une demi-heure pour pouvoir
conclure alors qui commence allez-y
le plan de qualité de la fibre je crois
qu'il y a une énorme impatience voilà
qui s'est manifesté on en a conscience
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
attendons nous aussi avec impatience qui
est des indicateurs qui soient déclinés
territoire par territoire qui soit rendu
public de la même façon qu'il y a eu des
indicateurs qui ont été mis en place qui
sont très riches notamment sur les
réseaux mobiles et qui permettent
d'objectiver territoire par territoire
ou est-ce que il y a des besoins de
combler les zones blanches avec des
dotations la NCT ou est-ce que il y a
une amélioration de la qualité de
service dans ces différentes dimensions
et donc la recette précisément a promis
d'ici l'été c'était une déclaration
publique de la présidente de rendre
public ces indicateurs qui vont là aussi
permettre d'apprécier territoire par
territoire ce qui a été fait il y a
beaucoup de députés ici notamment qui
ont parlé de la Haute-Savoie précisément
Haute-Savoie il y a un qui est très
accidentogène je rejette je regrette
d'ailleurs que l'opérateur
d'infrastructure n'est pas été présent
aujourd'hui pour répondre parce que
malheureusement c'est aucun d'entre nous
ici présent autour de cette table mais
il y a deux réseaux qui sont voisins sur
lesquels il y a deux réseaux qui sont
voisins sur lequel le taux
d'accidentologie varie de 1 à 10 il y a
un réseau de range qui est voisin donc
orange pourra pour un témoigner il y a
ce réseau d'opérateurs d'infrastructures
qui est présent dans lequel se concentre
beaucoup de difficultés pourquoi alors
ce que ce sont les mêmes intervenants
sur le terrain a-t-on des taux
d'accidentologie aussi
disparate donc c'est une vraie question
il y a aussi beaucoup de députés
composés des questions sur les armoires
les points de mutualisation qui sont
vandalisés précisément l'un des
dispositifs que l'on met en place
permettra avec un QR code c'est plus
moderne qui a une serrure pour lequel il
faut aller chercher la serrure etc qui
permettra avec un QR code d'identifier
l'intervenant qui est présent de
regarder quel acte il a fait
avec des photos qui vont être analysées
et qui vont permettre de savoir s'il y a
une malfaçon qui est à l'origine de
cette malfaçon qui en est responsable et
surtout comment la corriger le plus
rapidement possible parce que le but
c'est pas identifier les malfaçons c'est
vraiment d'y répondre le plus rapidement
possible donc c'est un dispositif qui
est tout frais qui vient d'être en place
qui est maintenant présent sur tous les
réseaux et qui sera un instrument
fondamental par rapport par ailleurs il
y a des zones dans lesquelles il y a du
vandalisme au sens généralisé qui est
présent aussi donc dans ces zones là il
peut y avoir des dispositifs de sécurité
renforcés qui sont absolument
nécessaires dans ces zones là aussi il
est prévu de renforcer les contrôles de
communiquer à l'avance les plannings
d'intervention pour pouvoir renforcer
les contrôles c'est en particulier le
cas dans une vingtaine de réseaux
d'initiatives publiques dont certains
connaissent des taux d'accidentologie
beaucoup plus élevés ce qui est prévu
aussi avec les sous-traitants nous avons
tous fait des efforts de revalorisation
de ces sous-traitants puisque nous leur
demandons plus de qualité nous allons
aussi surveiller encore plus sur le
terrain la sécurité en multipliant les
audits de sécurité et nous allons aussi
nous assurer de la réalité de la
formation et si on voit puisque
maintenant on a l'outil pour pouvoir
identifier qui est à l'origine d'une
malfaçon si on voit que il y a des
techniciens qui ont des malfaçons qui
sont répétés on peut obliger à les
remettre en formation et dans une
seconde phase si on voit qu'il y a
certains sous-traitants ou certaines
entreprises dans lesquelles il y a plus
de malfaçons on pourra aussi retirer les
certifications aux entreprises ou aux
techniciens
donc ce plan encore une fois on le met
en oeuvre il a fallu discuter avec toute
la filière notamment avec tous les
sous-traitants et là aussi c'était aussi
concomitant souvent à la revalorisation
donc ce plan on le met en oeuvre il faut
un peu de temps effectivement pour
qu'ils produisent ses effets sur en
particulier les réseaux les plus
accidentogènes il y a aussi cette
reprise des infrastructures il y a 3500
points de mutualisation sur les 200 000
que compte le territoire national qui
sont dans un plus mauvais état que les
autres donc il y a là aussi un plan de
reprise des infrastructures sachant que
les collectivités territoriales
concernées sont associés et peuvent
intervenir et être informés sur la mise
en oeuvre de ces plans il faut non
seulement reprendre les armoires ou
parfois les conceptions de réseau qui
sont plus du tout à l'état de l'art par
exemple dans certains réseaux il y a ce
qu'on appelle les boîtiers
multifonctions il y a pas la fibre
mutualisée donc là aussi il faut
remettre aux normes ces réseaux donc
nous avons vraiment conscience de tous
ces enjeux et nous mettons vraiment les
moyens nécessaires pour y répondre mais
comme le disait Nicolas c'est ce sont
vraiment des sujets qu'il faut traiter
au cas par cas parce que chaque réseau
est différent chaque typologie de
terrain est différente donc la réponse
emblée nationale mais elle est aussi
fortement déclinée et elle est fortement
adaptée à la spécificité de chacun de
ces réseaux il y a eu aussi des
questions donc sur le filtre anti-arnac
donc sur le projet de loi espace
numérique qui va être examiné en premier
lieu au Sénat nous trouvons que
effectivement il y a beaucoup de bonnes
avancées notamment sur ce filtre
anti-arna qui permettra d'identifier des
sites qui sont manifestement conçus pour
égarer pour les citoyens et les
consommateurs donc nous mettrons en
place un dispositif d'information
dès lors que dans 20 sms il y aura un
lien vers un site typiquement connu et
identifié par l'État comme étant un site
d'arnaque ensuite nous serons
extrêmement attentifs à la manière aussi
dont il sera décliné dans le décret en
Conseil d'État donc on est déjà en
discussion avec le gouvernement et asima
pour affiner le dispositif pour qu'il
soit le plus opérationnel possible il y
avait aussi donc il y avait aussi
énormément d'autres questions qui
étaient directement dirigée vers
certains opérateurs que j'invite à
compléter la réponse
bien qui souhaite continuer allez-y
monsieur Lombardini
et merci monsieur le Président
d'abord une petite
remarque générale enfin c'est
il y a un côté un petit peu déprimant
pour nous d'entendre toutes vos
critiques même si on reconnaît
l'existence des problèmes je crois que
vous avez quand même en France des
opérateurs qui ont fait preuve d'un très
fort engagement
j'essaie de répondre à plusieurs
questions en même temps avant de venir à
des points plus précis on a fait je dis
bien collectivement c'est pas que les
opérateurs c'est avec les collectivités
avec l'État une couverture qui est à la
française c'est à dire très égalitaire
on sait pas concentré sur le cœur des
grandes villes qui sont les endroits
rentables première chose deuxième chose
on sait pas gorgé de dividendes on sait
tous endettés lourdement c'est à dire
que nos bilans sont aujourd'hui très
chargés parce que depuis plusieurs
années et pour plusieurs années encore
les réseaux fixes coûtent du cash il
n'en génère pas quand vous quand vous
fibrez quelqu'un c'est à peu près 1500
euros d'investissement en face
on a les tarifs parmi les plus bas
d'Europe autour de 30 euros hors taxes
donc faites le calcul avant de retrouver
vos sous il se passe du temps quand même
on a dû également vendre des actifs
c'est à dire vendre nos pilotes vendre
parfois une partie de nos
infrastructures fibres pour financer
justement ce déploiement qui va très
très loin dans les territoires alors
certains d'entre vous trouvent qu'on a
été trop vite d'autres trouvent qu'on va
pas assez vite donc on essaye de faire
au mieux avec les contraintes
opérationnelles que l'on fait face et
puis la qualité ayez en tête que notre
seul actif ce sont nos abonnés donc on y
prend
la plus grande attention
on peut mesurer c'est vrai qu'on manque
un peu de statistiques vous dites vous
avez tous des exemples ils sont tout à
fait réels et légitimes qui a beaucoup
de problèmes nous on mesure pas ça dans
les dans les taux de satisfaction c'est
à dire qu'on a deux indicateurs qui sont
assez fiables c'est le taux de
désabonnement les abonnés qui nous
quittent tous les mois on a un
historique 25 ans sur la fibre ils sont
plus faibles que sur le cuivre et il
s'atténue même il diminue avec le temps
donc on n'est pas face à une
manifestation d'abonnés qui nous quitte
pour nous dire ça va pas et on mesure
également comme dans tous les métiers ce
qui s'appelle le NPS c'est une mesure de
la qualité de la satisfaction de la
monnaie et cette semaineps est plus
élevée sur la fibre qu'il n'est sur le
cuivre donc après on a ce plan de
qualité vous y croyez vous y croyez pas
nous on pense que c'est la seule vraie
solution comme le disait tout à l'heure
Nicolas Guérin c'est pas en changeant le
contrat V2 ou le mode opératoire en
confiant à Loïc ce que fait aujourd'hui
l'Océ on aura derrière les mêmes
intervenants sur le terrain les
sous-traitants nous on a également 3000
salariés qui font du raccordement des
CDI c'est pas des sous-traitants donc on
peut faire des comparatifs les
sous-traitants travaillent pas plus mal
ou pas mieux on est face à des
techniciens se conforme aussi bien les
sous-traitants que nos CDI donc on
entend tout à fait vos critiques elles
viennent du terrain on n'est pas des
opérateurs parisiens ça c'est une
remarque qu'on entend souvent on va
beaucoup sur le terrain on a beaucoup
d'équipes sur le terrain on a beaucoup
recruté nous chez Free mais mes
camarades également donc on n'est pas
dans une approche où on se dit on va
mettre ça à des sous-traitants pas cher
on essaye de faire les choses bien et
donc c'est vrai que c'est il y a un côté
un petit peu décevant même s'il est
légitime à entendre vos récriminations
plus que vos satisfactions mais soyez
bien convaincus qu'on prend ça à bras le
corps parce que perdre un abonné c'est
un crève-cœur ça coûte très cher de
conquérir un abonné on est sur un marché
on est quatre opérateurs concurrents
donc on a en France des prix très bas je
le répète et madame chikiro je suis pas
du tout d'accord avec vous sur le fait
que les prix augmentés on a forfait sur
le mobile à 2 euros c'est quelque chose
qui est quand même unique en Europe et
qui je pense est accessible et sur le
fixe les prix sont également très bas
vous pouvez comparer partout ailleurs
alors après c'est jamais assez bas
peut-être mais on n'est pas sur un
territoire sur lequel les prix sont
élevés donc voilà c'est juste pour vous
redire notre engagement après juste très
brièvement mutualisation mobile on y est
très favorable après ça bute parfois sur
des contrats d'opérationnels d'une part
c'est que les réseaux radio parfois ont
des contraintes et puis après des
contraintes de temps également on nous
demande de déployer vite et quand il
faut faire un pylône commun ça va
toujours moins vite maintenant toute
disposition qui forcerait à plus de
mutualisation n'y est favorable et
Monsieur bottorel sur le filtre anti
arnaque on accompagnera bien sûr il y a
besoin de quelques réunions sur les
modalités opérationnelles mais ça répond
à un besoin
légitime
sur la mutualisation juste un rappel
dans les zones non denses qui sont les
seules zones dans lesquelles on peut
faire la mutualisation sinon on a un
infraction avec la législation sur les
ondes le taux de mutualisation atteint
de 75% donc là aussi on est dans les
dans les pays les plus mutualisés en
Europe et c'est évidemment l'intérêt
naturel des opérateurs d'infrastructures
mobiles que de mutualiser évidemment les
pylônes pour maximiser leur
bien qui souhaitent poursuivre allez-y
monsieur
Éric Bothorel oui on soutient évidemment
toutes les initiatives sur la
cybersécurité à partir du moment où il y
a les garanties procédurales vous le
savez on se les dit plein de fois range
et très impliqué dans la cyber défense
avec OCD et donc tout dispositif qui
permet de sécuriser nos concitoyens et
effectivement à prendre en compte encore
une fois il faut le faire dans le
respect du droit mais je sais qu'il y a
pas de souci de ce point de vue là
peut-être pour répondre aux questions
plus spécifiques oranges vous avez parlé
de partage de la valeur madame tout à
l'heure madame la députée donc la
sous-traitance augmentation de 3 5% la
dernière 4% cette année donc on rémunère
mieux nous sous-traitant la NAO on
m'avait parlé pardon les accords
salariaux on a eu 3,7% d'augmentation et
dernière 4,8 cette année avec un accord
signé par les organisations syndicales
20% de chiffre d'affaires est investi
dans les réseaux est à plus de 20 % de
chiffre d'affaires est investi dans les
réseaux donc je crois qu'on équilibre
assez bien entre la rémunération des
salariés là le traitement de nous
certains peut-être qu'on les contrôle
pas assez mais en tout cas on essaie de
le rémunérer pour justement qu'il n'y
ait plus aucune excuse sur la qualité et
puis les investissements dans les
réseaux ou je vous assure on est présent
dans 22 pays africains 8 pays européens
la France et le pays où on investi le
plus 9 milliards dans les réseaux fibrés
donc quand on dit qu'on ne partage pas
la valeur chez Orange on estime qu'on la
partage effectivement alors on peut
toujours être pas d'accord sur les clés
de d'allocation de cette partie mais le
partage est fait en tenant compte de
toutes les parties prenantes de toutes
les parties prenantes vous avez parlé
monsieur de procédure d'urgence oui on
est en train de travailler sur ces
sujets là on a des représentants locaux
qui sont à votre disposition ça ne
suffit pas
on a des représentants locaux qui sont à
votre disposition on a mis en place des
systèmes de signal réseau etc ça ne
suffit pas il faut qu'on retravaille
effectivement sur ces procédures ça fait
partie des débats qu'on a en ce moment
effectivement pour ce sera sans doute
pas un septième plan parce que ça
devient ridicule donc il est des plans
comme ça etc mais clairement on a un
sujet dans le cadre des commissionnement
du cuivre il faut voilà jusqu'à 2030 et
surtout on a un petit sujet je me
permets de le dire aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a essayé de maintenir
jusqu'à maintenant et c'était logique
une qualité de service qui ne vous
satisfait pas mais qui était sur tous
les territoires maintenant on va pouvoir
entrer dans des phases de la qualité de
service va être affectée au territoire
qui n'ont peut-être pas qui basculeront
pas tout de suite sur la fibre et donc
et ces réseaux là sont priorisés je
pense je l'espère en tout cas on y
travaille effectivement pour la qualité
soit renforcée dans ces eaux là versus
les zones où il faudra peut-être
basculer aller plus vite vers la fibre
ok on le fera on le verra je crois que
c'était les deux questions très bien
merci beaucoup monsieur Halimi non
vous allez la prendre monsieur aliments
appuyez sur le bouton voilà comme ça
c'est parfait
soyons clairs non respectons la loi
tous nos équipements doivent être
autorisés par l'annecy nous respectons
ces décisions même si
je vous le dis nous avons d'ores et déjà
entamé nos swap nous travaillons
également avec d'autres équipes entiers
comme comme Nokia qui sont sur toute la
chaîne de g3g 4g 5G donc que les choses
soient claires nous sommes en conformité
avec la loi et ses dispositions
s'agissant de de
la Savoie comme vous savez monsieur la
Savoie
[Musique]
était sous l'escarcelle de du était sous
l'escarcelle de Covage que xpecifié va
arracher il y a maintenant il y a
maintenant deux ans
tout nous sous-traitants sans exclusion
sont soumis aux consignes de sécurité
malheureusement il arrive et je connais
le cas que vous avez cité il arrive que
certains
certaines personnes sur le terrain ne
respectent pas ces consignes de sécurité
on met en place des plantes prévention
et à chaque fois qu'on constate
justement des manquements aux consignes
de sécurité nous travaillons avec les
services du département pour
systématiquement stopper les chantiers
et faire un rappel à l'ordre des
consignes de sécurité
s'agissant de l'utilisation des
infrastructures le principe de base
c'est nous utilisons les infrastructures
existantes à savoir les infrastructures
aériennes d'orange
d'enedis nous avons été contraints par
des délais courts donc oui nous
utilisons ces infrastructures et
nous avançons au plus vite pour
respecter les
une séance contractuelles mais je tiens
à préciser une chose
s'agissons également puisque vous
parliez des des PM des armoires des
armoires de rue qui ne sont c'est pas
vous
en tout cas on en a on en a parlé donc
si c'est pas vous ça doit être un de vos
un de vos collègues contrairement aux
autres infrastructures autre qualité
comme
on a nos infrastructures ne sont pas
essentiellement dans les immeubles sont
à l'extérieur vous avez ces armoires de
rue vous avez ces PM donc par définition
ce sont des infrastructures qui sont
beaucoup plus exposées que d'autres
types d'infrastructures tous les
dispositifs de sécurisation ne sont pas
parfaits il faut le reconnaître
c'est très compliqué il y a des mesures
qui sont mis en place de la sécurisation
des dispositifs des dispositifs avec des
NFC avec des SMS mais ça prend du temps
à être
mis en place mais sachez que par
définition
aujourd'hui il y a plus d'incidents
puisqu'il y a beaucoup d'interventions
sur le réseau au titre du déploiement
une fois que le réseau sera déployé il y
aura moins d'interventions et donc il y
aura moins d'incidents
en tout cas nous en tout cas nous
travaillons nous travaillons ce sens
nous travaillons ce sens et enfin
concernant les augmentations tarifaires
je suis au regret de vous dire que
nous ne constatons pas d'augmentation de
tarifaire de l'ordre de 20% mais nous
parlons de montant bien
moindre
la France aujourd'hui sous le contrôle
de mes camarades est probablement un des
pays d'Europe ou les autres moments sont
le moins cher que ce soit aussi bien sur
le mobile que que sur le fixe alors que
en contrepartie nous avons des
investissements dans les infrastructures
qui sont astronomiques qui ne cessent
d'augmenter de par le déploiement de par
l'utilisation de la bande passante par
par les Gafa on en a déjà on en a parlé
tout à l'heure avec le TFR et croyez moi
que toute l'augmentation de ces
investissements n'est pas répercuté sur
le client final en tout cas pas sur les
sur les sur les tarifs de détails
merci beaucoup monsieur de Tournade
allez-y
appuyez sur le bouton
également été interpellé sur la question
Huawei donc affirmer également ici que
nous sommes en total conformité avec la
loi et que nous avons tous les agréments
obtenus
de la part de l'encens de Lancy pardon
voilà
attendez histoire qu'on entend bien
quand vous si vous jouez décidé de
reprendre la parole vous coupez votre
micro et vous l'allumez à côté allez-y
sachant pour donner une perspective
européenne donc la France a pris des
restrictions qui sont appliquées et donc
notamment par SFR et Bouygues Telecom
mais que elle est au juste milieu et
notamment qu'en Allemagne en Espagne à
ce jour il n'y a absolument aucune
restriction bien allez-y messieurs de
Tournade alors je vais le poursuivre
également sur une autre question qui a
été soulevée notamment dans le Bas-Rhin
sur les questions des zones mobiles pas
ou mal couvertes et rappeler qui est un
dispositif qui existe depuis 2018 c'est
le dispositif de couverture ciblée du
New Deal mobile qui permet à tous les
élus d'un département de remonter les
besoins identifiés au sein de l'équipe
projet local qui piloté par la
préfecture et qui permet ensuite
d'arbitrer au niveau départemental les
besoins les faire remonter à l'Agence
nationale de cohésion les territoires et
ensuite de débloquer une dotation pour
permettre effectivement
la complétude de la couverture ça c'est
un dispositif qui marche bien et vous
pouvez y faire appel bien évidemment
voilà soit effectivement sur la qualité
nous avons également revalorisé nos
sous-traitants on a aussi nous-mêmes
simplifier nos procédures pour laisser
plus de temps dans le geste technique et
voilà qui était moins de voilà de de de
procédure un peu administrative et qui
passe plus de temps sur le geste
technique
[Musique]
bien est-ce que l'un de vous souhaitez
rajouter quelque chose
c'est bon mais écoutez merci pour votre
temps merci pour votre disponibilité et
la qualité de vos réponses chers
collègues avant de vous libérer je
voulais juste vous faire quand même
quelques annonces parce que le planning
est très chargé dans les jours qui
viennent
demain jeudi 25 mai à 11h on a la CMP
sur la proposition de loi influenceurs
qui se déroulera au Sénat mardi 30 mai
donc à 17h30 on aurait l'examen de la
proposition de loi maintenant
provisoirement un dispositif de
plafonnement de revalorisation de la
variation annuelle des indices locatifs
le 31 mai à 9h30 au noir une table ronde
avec les opérateurs d'infrastructures de
téléphonie donc c'est bien prévu et on
aura dès la semaine prochaine et le
jeudi 1er juin à 9h on aura l'audition
de Thierry Breton conjointe avec la
commission des affaires européennes
voilà planning donc chargé dans les
jours qui viennent merci de votre
présence et merci encore à nos invités
pour vos réponses merci beaucoup